foreign
thank you
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
I don't like to say
good morning everyone welcome to labor
District council's planning committee I
will now ask the government officer to
read out the domestic arrangements and
the fire regulations
okay thank you chair
please do not interrupt other speakers
or hold separate conversations whilst
others are speaking if you're attending
the meeting to speak and persistently
interrupt the meeting you may be asked
to leave
please ensure your mobile phones are on
silent or switched off and that your
laptop is also switched to silence we
will be using e-voting for this meeting
on the body Club app so please give
members make sure they are logged in and
ready to use the app
fire safety Arrangements there are no
planned apply drills today so if you
hear the alarm please leave the building
immediately by a fire exit and make your
way to the assembly point do not
re-enter the building until told it's
safe to do so
the council's members of the public and
press May record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and press are not lawfully excluded
thank you Jeff thank you
some introductions to my left the chief
planning officer for this bowl
um to the far right Stephen Stroud
the area planning manager Mark Russell
who's behind me somewhere and legal
advisor in to pray
and case officers present today are
Vincent Pierce Elizabeth flood Rose
Walton and Owen fairs we have a highways
officer from County Manchester and
you've spoken to the and you've met
governance obviously Clearfield
can we move on apologies for absence and
substitution
the councilor Hinton and councilor
Dawson is substituting for Council of
Barrett
Council B you have your hand up thank
you Mr chairman I just want to register
my objection to us having to come to
this building today I know you weren't
happy about it I know you tried I accept
that but I do feel that the senior
officers who had to have made this
decision didn't make it in the interest
of the people I represent and quite a
few of the residents I represent are
disappointed because they could cannot
get here easily so I I like that to be
recorded in the minutes Mr chairman
thank you noted thank you
foreign
Declarations of Interest
you know
Jack
if I can just it's not a declaration of
interest but I would just like to make a
statement that um I've had some previous
involvement in the in the Bellevue sites
however I can confirm that I'm
approaching this planned decision in an
open mind that will base my decision on
the balance of facts presented I just
want to make that statement initially up
front thank you thank you
Professor Davis yeah I'd just like to
point out that I'm Baba's representative
on the Soviet Coastal aonb represents
for application number of four
councilor Osborne thank you Mr chairman
um yes I'll declare I'm a Sudbury Town
councilor as well although My Views are
of of this planning committee thank you
thank you thanks for advice me yeah oh
sorry
Dave I've got to stop taking those pills
I think obviously I've got to declare an
Ori which I understand is not catching
but it's an other um
interest which is for chair of Labor
growth but I do have dispensation for
that thank you councilor owie I would
like to also say that I'm part of the
subway Town Council and I had voted on
this before but I'm here with an open
mind thank you very much
moving on you've had the minutes of the
meeting held on the 27th of July
are there any points regarding the
accuracy of these minutes
if not in that case can I please have a
proposal cancer Osborne I can have a
secretary councilor Jameson that they be
received
excuse me chair there was a point I
wanted to make about the minutes I am
sorry there's a point about that I'd
like to make about the minute it's a
clarification on 16.4
page
nine
two
um
compute
um
yes though I did ask a question about
the
The Wider site entrance of a pedestrian
and Cycle Way
what I wanted though was I wanted more
assurance that we were going to get it I
didn't want just the question that
why it haven't been delivered under this
application and I'd like it minuteed
that I would want one of the planning
officers to respond to that point as to
when we are going to get that new
entrance
okay so the sugar beet site which will
allow pedestrian and cycle entrants
to Hadley Road
may I um can I be heard um
I think central councilor Busby's aware
as an experienced member minutes are
normally a concise distillation of quite
a lot of
growing
in a meeting I think what's on the paper
is accurate as far as it goes I think
your point is you'd like a bit more
detail but it's I mean normally we don't
descend to a great deal of detail in
minutes
it's like it records the decisions made
and I understand that but this is
probably the fifth planning application
that we've had now that I've raised this
point and so far nothing's been done
about it I need it to be registered
well it's I think it's
what were you looking for councilor
Busby in terms of I want to know when
it's going to be delivered
right and who's going to be paying for
it we keep allowing planning
applications to proceed without any
request for funding towards the delivery
of this entrance
you'll get to the point where there's
one small shed at the end that wants
planning application and we're going to
be charging them 10 million pounds for a
cycleway I think what I would suggest
chairman is that if the committee are
minded to approve these minutes as they
stand because they are they are I think
they are it's being accepted they're
accurate but if there could be a note in
the minutes of this meeting the
councilor Busby reiterated the concern
when the minutes were being discussed
Council must be reiterated his concern
from 16.4 and said he still had ongoing
concerns about that okay would that be
acceptable well cheers if I can suggest
Council Busby's obviously got some
questions arising from 16.4 it seems to
be right for officers to respond to
councilors beyond that I mean this is
you will recall an application for
approval of Reserve matters
so you don't have the ability to to go
back to the beginning of the outline
planning application process which is
obviously in place for those of the
matters to come forward
but In fairness to Castle Busby's
question I think there's one for
officers to take away and come back to
aside from the question of the minutes
certainly
okay so if we carry on
vote for the approval of the minutes
of Hope yeah just pick up on what
council advisory said and I appreciate
that you've planning office officers
reply but we did specific request the
last meeting that officers came back to
us not necessarily to be minuted but I
don't know if the chief plan officer is
aware but we ask for officers to come
back to us with all the conditions that
are applied to that application
initially so that we ensure that all
those conditions were being met and that
were properly funded was properly
allocated and available to deliver those
conditions I think that's what we all
agreed that we'd like last time we met
so could the chief plan officer make
sure that that happens and that a report
comes back to the committee
accept thank you
can we carry on with the vote please yes
thank you chair that vote is now in
progress members
councilor Dawson
would you like to vote verbally uh yes
Paul thank you
foreign
thank you members chair that's 11 votes
for that's unanimous thank you very much
moving on
having noted Mr councilor both was in
Council holds request
receive notification for petitions
thank you chair yes we have received a
validated petition and respective
application number dc2106519
the petition has a total of 23 verified
signatures a previous repetition was
received with a total of 249 names
whether this was rejected as there were
no signatures included
petition reads as follows
we the undersigned wish to petition
against the development of the former
swimming pool side at Bellevue Park in
Sudbury into a multi-story block of 42
living units by Church of retirement
limited living and to the development of
Bellevue house into two private
dwellings by McCabe and Abel
need for these developments offers
affordable housing which is in chronic
short supply Churchill's planning
application removes existing pedestrian
access to the park from the Town Center
the former swimming pool skate park
outside is open space as defined by the
open space Act of 1906.
the government's National filing policy
framework states that open space
Recreation land should not be built on
unless an assessment shows the space to
the Surplus to requirements
this is not the case at Bellevue baber's
own 2019 open space assessment
highlighted concerns over the
substantial 24-acre deficit of Park and
recreational land in Sudbury Sudbury
needs more open space of this kind and
cannot afford to lose more
Bellevue house is a much lower part of
sudbury's history and was a Community
Asset used by the public for a wide
variety of purposes over many years it
is neither fitting nor respectful to
sell it to just two families
there are serious issues about the
increased traffic flow resulting from
further development of Sudbury busiest
Junction poor accessibility to these
sites and the detrimental effect on the
environment of the Town Center
so yeah
moving on
site inspections
do you have a requests for site
inspection yes we do Chad Gemma Walker
will event
uh yeah I've got a committee site visit
request from Council hardacre on land
north of the a1071 which members may be
more familiar with as part of the
Woolsey Grange
proposal the application in this case is
an outline for up to 750 dwellings up to
three hectares of primary education land
public open space sustainable Urban
drainage landscaping and Highway
improvements and the request by
councilor hardik was due to listed
buildings the garnishing Birds drainage
concerns and the topography
so we've got the application site
outlined in partly and pink and partly
in Orange and just to the very south is
the land known as Water Grange one and
then we've got the A14 essentially
running through the center of that
slide so we can see and again we've got
the red line there which is the
application site and in Blue part of the
Water Grange one development so we've
got the Hadley Road that essentially
runs to the South and the A14 which runs
to the west and church Park is the large
area in green on that side
it does have some constraints we can see
there we've got the flood zone partly
running through
and apologies and some list of buildings
we've got spring um sorry Poplar Farm
which is in the very bottom corner
um
on potentially the water grain to one
site we've got Springvale apologies
members I can't point to these but
Springvale which is
um close to the A14 and we've got Red
House Farm Central to the site and
finally Challenger Park
with a variety of distributions and
Parkland
The Proposal said is for residential and
it's been a variety of aspects of The
Proposal Part of the area that would be
flood zone is not being proposed for
development but would be retained as
open space
what would I suggested development plans
you can see the area to the north
wouldn't be developed and then we've got
various Parcels of residential
development and the pink area to the
South is the proposed School land
and again a sort of a green
infrastructure plan which perhaps shows
more clearly the different areas of land
proposed for the development
possible building Heights proposed
maximum residential density so all of
those areas are things they have thought
of in terms of the built development
and just very briefly I've got some
slides of from the landscape official
impact assessment to give an idea of
what it might look like so this is Red
House Farm essentially in the valley and
this is proposed
um
spring Year One
summer Year One
and we go on through to year 15 spring
and summer and I've got similar views
across which I briefly run through to
give members an idea of some of the
information we've got so again we're now
looking up from adjacent to Red House
Farm
looking through Year One
and through again
to what this might look like with some
of the landscape plants and that's
proposed
right with the housing on the hill in
this case
and again with some of the landscape
planting proposed
so you can have an idea of some of the
mitigation and some of the views that we
do have
on here
these are slightly more distant views
hopefully you can just see on the
horizon in this case the proposed
development and then the landscape
interposed going forward
I do have some photos if members would
like me to run through them in
essentially care that is the request for
the site visit if members would like
more I'm happy to run through more now
but conscious that might be sufficient
thank you
would everyone like to see more
while they're here
yes yes please yeah
so we're looking up to the cop talk
um Interchange to our rights through
across the Suffolk one and the
application sites to the left in this
case
and they're looking down the hill so
these are views from
approximately two weeks ago
and then again looking down this part of
the water grained one surface water
drainage that goes down the valley but
it would be part of the sort of central
to the wars we're going to two sites
and again looking down the valley
and again we're looking back up with
Suffolk one and the holiday into our
right and the application side to our
left
and looking down again from the Hadley
Road
and then we're just bar coming down the
junction from Hadley Road um we're
looking we've got the Springvale to our
left with the um swimming pool and
various buildings in there to the left
looking down the road and the bottom of
that Hill is the Red House Farm and
again we've got the application site
both to our left hand to our right going
down this road
and then looking back up that's the um
traffic lights would be just slightly
out of our view on that one again
applications like both sides of the road
and we're looking down then to Red House
farmhouse
and closest to The Farmhouse
and again looking across the through the
site either side
and again the Red House Farmhouse from
the other side so we're looking up
essentially towards the traffic lights
and the remainder Falls around one is up
and to our left
and get more of the sites areas and the
roads surrounding so again we're just
looking up the hill Church Park to our
right up into Ipswich
and across the view up towards the
ground one again
that's all the photos I have chair but
I'm happy if the members will get more
on the day thank you Chan questions from
anyone yes no I was just to propose that
we it's not very clear on there I would
like to say and it's not your photos
it's nothing it's because where it is
but I would propose that we go and go
and see it because like anything we need
to visit things to make sure we're doing
this right
that's your current flowey here we have
a second there
yeah I'll second that yeah I think to do
to the scale and size of this I think
it's uh I think all the committee would
rather be out there looking at it uh
with their feet on the ground so how do
you support that
any other questions from members
if not I'd like you to vote on
a proposal that's been made
thank you chair members that vote is in
progress
foreign
thank you members chair that's 11 votes
for that's unanimous
very much
Council Osborne thank you Mr chairman
yes is that um is there a date for that
site visit please
I believe the proposed date will be the
17th is that correct Gemma
17 which is next thank you
Council McLaren uh cheers I'm sorry
um I can I give my apologies now because
I'm going on leave tomorrow and I'll be
away for that site inspection so I would
not be accessible to refuse the
invitation thank you okay
I'm sorry I have to give my apologies as
well for the 17th I'm absent on holiday
don't think there's a lot of people on
holiday at the moment and perhaps we
could look in September all right thanks
to Jameson and the same I will apologize
in that case that's over half of you've
already
expressed a delay do you want to have a
rethink
yeah if you leave that with us we can
confirm something later
today
thank you
All Right
Moving On
schedule planning applications
are you ready Vincent I am too good
um Bellevue park at the junction of
roundabout and Corner Road Newton Road I
invited the case officer Minister Pierce
to introduce the application to the
committee
no
thank you chair good morning members our
guests in the audience here at uh
worsted Park and anyone who may be
watching and listening online first
application this morning
is dc22
00985
which is a council owned development
proposal for the creation of a new
entrance to Bellevue Park in Sudbury and
it involves the demolition of the old
open-air swimming pool wall
the site actually is on the edge of the
ward of Sudbury Southwest and you can
see that uh to other sudden Rewards
are join
as is always the tradition I have to say
that this presentation is merely
designed to illustrate items in the
report and he's won a number of material
considerations that you are required to
take into account on top of the report
and representations that you may hear
this morning
just to flag up for the sake of public
transparency this is a council owned
site the applicant is the council that
said as the planning committee you must
judge it as you would judge any other
application made by any other applicant
extensive consultations and you'll
notice there's been
a
significant
public interest concern 59 public
objections they are all referred to in
part two of the committee report and all
those comments have been available
online
Sudbury sits to the west of
of Hadley and on the screen we've just
shown you some of those distances so
it's approximately nine and a half miles
west of Hadley 18 miles west of
Ipswich
zoom in so we're zooming in into Sudbury
right into the heart of Sudbury King
Street the application site is at the
Eastern end of King Street
the application site is shown in red on
the screen
so
and an aerial shot showing it in the
context of
Bellevue Park which is the green area
that extends in the Triangular shape to
the right hand side of the screen with
Bellevue house sitting just to the north
of the park
so a quick look at policy matters in
respect of this proposal
the first slide I'm showing you is an
extract from the adopted local plan
which shows
the frontage of this site where the
entrance will be as mixed use area
Bellevue Park which is shown in green
within the local plan is allocated as
open space and Recreation
uses
so actually the entrance Arrangement is
within what is
allocated mixed use area but it's
obviously essentially connected to the
open space because it is providing a
long-awaited new entrance to the park
we are referring to the baby local plan
2016 2006 2006.
sorry 2006.
Mr chairman could you ask the police
officer if he could just point out I
think it was on slide number six
uh where cornard road is and where it
ends at the roundabout I I think I know
where it is but I don't know where other
people do because we don't have access
to a pointer and we're not working from
a laptop with your permission chairman
all right I'm afraid
region now
it's the old-fashioned way
yep
yep
here on the King Street here Great
Eastern Road could you just while you're
there point to
The Junction at the end of Coronado Road
hitting the roundabout with the road
coming from Newton that's right there
thank you that's where the entrance is
thank you
well I think probably you're not going
to be seen and
um listeners cannot see the screen
either so
perhaps just so that members of the
public know I know they know the area
sorry
chair while he's doing that it's obvious
that we can't see this I know
could we move these screens closer so
that we can see those
and then at least everybody should have
a better
we've asked the question you've been
told that sunlight they can't turn it
off but
can we do something about it no it's
these screens these are clear if they if
they moved 10 foot closer yeah
you've just turned it off
before you've broken it yeah if we could
if we could just wait for the I.T people
please
I think
thank you
cool can you turn it around a bit
Michael towards us at all
that's it thank you
thank you Vincent
I think we need to carry on trying to
make do the best screen we have
time please carry out
foreign
I just want to point out to the
committee
particularly in terms of the nppf
paragraph 92
because this application is designed to
enhance access to Bellevue Park
and 92b
requires you when you're making a
decision
in terms of open space to ensure that we
are considering safe and accessible
accesses
crime and disorder fear of crime quality
of life
community
cohesion
legible pedestrian and cycle routes high
quality public space
so the council is promoting this new
access
in large part to achieve
those objectives it's been a long-haired
ambition of the council to improve
access to Bellevue Park and this is part
of that
strategy
I refer specifically to the open space
Sport and Recreation strategy
from 2010 which goes back as far as 2010
where the professed objection of
objective of the council is
to improve the main entrance to Bellevue
Park amongst other things so up on the
screen you can see that extract
so when I say it's been a long-held
ambition
hopefully this is the coming together of
a lot of effort to improve Bellevue Park
quick look at the constraints
as you can see on the screen there are a
large number of listed buildings close
by
largely grade two
SD buildings it's on the edge of a
Conservation Area Sudbury Conservation
Area
and also we've got some Peter's Church
which is a grade one listed building
shown in green on that screen there is a
public footpath shown in the green
dashed line in the bottom left hand side
of that shot
we also have to have regard to the fact
that Bieber is fortunate in having a
number of buildings that are on the
local list that's not a Desi uh
officially designated heritage
designation
but at least two groups of buildings
within this area have been identified as
having Heritage worth and of Worth to
the community that is Bellevue house
which is the building on the
top right circle on the screen
adjacent to Bellevue Park and Cottages
one to six in cornard Road
in the vicinity of the proposed entrance
so we will have regard to the impact on
on those of this proposal
fortunately there are no flood issues
that will impact this proposal whether
that's fluvial or fluvial and that's
evidenced on the screen
the area is designated as an area where
there's an asset of community value
clearly it's a much loved part of
Sudbury and there is a lot of community
passion to ensure that it's
kept in in good order and a facility for
the community
in terms of context what would we expect
of an urban park and on the screen I've
I've got a selection of images of other
parks within
Suffolk and one in Colchester
and I think where you're looking at an
urban park it's part of the whole civic
pride in having that facility to make
a statement about its entrance that
needs to be welcoming needs to draw
people in and it's a statement about how
much we love the park
and as you can see we've got examples
from lower stuffed Felix Stowe Ipswich
and what we're trying to do is recreate
that rather formal grand entrance
to say to people here's the park it's
got some fantastic facilities inside and
this is the best way to access it
directly from the Town Center
so it's part of a Revival of the Eastern
end of
Sudbury
these are the Cottages in question that
are on the local list one two one to six
they have all the wind the original
details in terms of Windows and Doors
have been replaced largely with upvc but
you can see that are not unattractive
group of
workers cottages
closer look at the wall this is the wall
that faces the roundabout that councilor
beer asked me to identify and this is
what was the wall around the old
open-air pool
as you can see well it might be
difficult at the distance but where my
yellow line is clearly that wall has
either been repaired or the height has
been raised at some point
um
largely
English Bond it does have buttresses the
whole way along there's a large area of
concrete on the left hand side closest
to Newton Road
it does add something to that corner
it's a
um
in Urban Design terms but there's a war
it's not particularly
attractive in its current
condition there you can see the large
bit of concrete there's a hodgepodge of
repair some of it not particularly good
but it does make a statement on that
corner
and there we have a view down cornard
Road
another shot where the trees are
overhanging the wall along cornard Road
here we have a an aerial shot in the
distance there you can see Bellevue
house nestling in the trees Midway on
the right is actually the access to the
park from Newton Road
so where that copper looks like a copper
Beach is that is the access point into
the park
so let's see what it is that the council
is proposing in terms of
I have got a closer shot so we can look
in in some detail but the other the idea
is to demolish the war that's currently
in that position on the Frontage and
replace it with a series of steps and
ramps leading to a rather Grand formal
gated entrance to make a real statement
about the
the park
we zoom in closer what we can see is
there is also a new Crossing and this
has caused quite a lot of controversy in
the ERA this will be a if it's approved
a controlled Crossing so I'm not sure
whether I've highlighted that on screen
so on the left hand side across the road
you'll see that cross hatched area that
will be
a controlled crossing the details of
which we don't have so it could be a
a toucan it could be a pelican but that
would be a matter for the highway
Authority under Section 278 of the
highway act were you minded to Grant
planning permission
and I'll go into the concerns that have
been expressed but
in a nutshell
people are concerned that this might not
be the safest location for a Crossing in
terms of its position in relation to the
roundabout and traffic activity around
that that point and we'll deal with that
in a moment but the actual entrance
detail itself because there's a
difference in level between
conard Road and the park of some three
meters
we've had to create this I say where
it's our colleagues in in regeneration a
series of
stepped access points so there's these
two step access points and a series of
ramps so that we can Ensure
a good DDA compliance to get access into
the park and I will show you in more
detail how it
how it works councilor berries
indicating You may wish to speak Mr
chairman I wanted to ask a question on
that point but it may come up but the
wall that you show in coronard road
which was the bottom end of the swimming
pool and holding the bank up behind
there was a little shop when the
swimming pool was in existence a sweet
shop but how far along
is that wall being Incorporated in that
new piece of improvement
does it go all the way the length of
that wall
or not you you know what I'm referring
to now thank you
it is the entire length of that wall and
there will be a new retaining wall
at the north of that
shot
so at the bottom corner no that's right
I have to do this again because I've got
no other way of pointing things out I do
I I need to know because I've got lots
of questions on this later I can do with
that in a later slide can we finish
the presentation and leave our questions
to where they should probably be after
we've had the full
presentation thank you it's difficult
so
I'll play that again
on the aerial shot you'll see how it the
majority of that wall disappears
around the end of what was the old
swimming pool
but incorporated into the new feature is
a new retaining wall
that we will take it all the way around
that corner so there will still be a
wall on that corner
but it'll be a new wall
and we've got some details to come
that's a closer shot so you can see what
was the old pull it's been filled in
assume we've concrete and tarmac over so
some of those buildings used to be the
old pool buildings and in the core of
that
is what was the swimming pool
so as you can see
a large part of the swimming pool area
is being replaced by this new entrance
across the site as I said there's a
difference on this part of the site of
some three meters but generally the land
does that so in terms of the roundabout
and Bellevue there's a difference of six
meters but for the entrance it's three
meters so you can see the land generally
Rises to the East and then from the
south it rises to meet that sort of bun
that runs right the way along
that section of Newton Road
it highlighted some of those differences
for you which is about three meters
the yellow shows the proposed location
of the Crossing
so at the moment and including this
feature what
in terms of accessibility
there are a whole series of Crossing
points that you could make from the
north
from King Street through that central
island that exists
that they'd all take you to this point
and then of course what you'd have
here is something that you don't have on
other parts of that
round about you would have a new
controlled Crossing which would actually
stop traffic so that you could cross
safely and that would then allow you to
access the park
from that point
this is the point that it has come up in
terms of the ramp
is it wide enough to ensure that two
buggies
double buggies could could pass
so as you can see from the screen I've
measured it in detail the actual width
of the ramp is two meters
there's a bit of research I looked to
see what mum's net have to say about
the best double buggies and taking their
two best examples
one of which is the sort of all-terrain
double buggy so not the one the tend on
the one in front of the other side by
side you can accommodate
passing double buggies on every point of
that that ramp it will be DDA compliant
so it will have the correct gradients it
will have the platforms
so we're very confident that is
an excellent access for everyone to get
into the park but if you chose to you
could walk up the
up the steps
and again I've got some slides to show
how that actually works in detail but
going back to the crossing and the
concern is and it
it it's a genuine concern as you can see
on cornard Road
outside of the cottage on the corner
close to us around about the pavement
width
is narrow
but this scheme includes
building out
to create a nib pedestrian nib to widen
the footpath
so what we would have is a foot path
that is 2.3 meters wide
right the way around to 4.5 meters
wide there is a short section between
here and the remainder of cornard road
where the footpath remains narrow but at
the moment anyone walking up cornard
Road
has to clearly try and cross
between that corner
and the opposite side with no Aid
whatsoever
so I think what we're saying is to have
a controlled Crossing would be a
significant benefit in terms of a
pedestrian safety
so here we have a shot
taken that from Great Eastern
that road looking down cornard
Road and I take so the crossing would be
broadly in that position there where the
yellow with the white
I also have to say that that's the
position is indicative now that could
move closer to the roundabout a little
bit further back that is a matter for
the highway Authority in terms of the
section 278 agreement now I know that
some people have expressed concern that
perhaps that's too close
to the roundabout
but when you look at sorry let me just
I'll walk you around that corner because
I don't want to underplay the concern
there is locally about safety so here we
are on that wide section looking towards
the wall so this was 4.4 meters
wide
so we'll just walk plenty of space at
that point now remember as we start
going around this corner that footway
will be built out into the road so it
will be widened as we go around that
corner
at that point you have the Crossing
but then it does narrow in front of the
Cottages
you'll also notice that once you get
past the cottage I think that was was
that the college I think it's probably
the college the rest of cornard Road on
that side of the road had a very wide
footpath
that is also a cycle route cycleway so
as you approach the roundabout along
cornard Road you're cycling on the
pavement and then you are encouraged to
drop back into the road to get past the
college building and one to six
cornard Road
that is something cyclists are very
familiar with doing on cornard road
which leaves the rest of the payment
free for pedestrians on that narrow
section
what I wanted to show you here is how
close a Crossing can be to a roundabout
this is Great Eastern Road
that's almost on the radius of that that
roundabout
so there's the radius of the roundabout
and that's where you cross
what we're suggesting here is of course
this wouldn't be uncontrolled what we
would have in cornard road is actually a
light that you could press traffic stops
and you cross
a series of shots of
so we're looking towards Borum gate
I took this yesterday lunchtime it was
busy
uh lots of traffic trying to get into
Sudbury we swing around King Street
and then we have the wall
in cornard Road there's a section of the
park wall that's that's missing and I
don't know how long that Harris railing
has been
I imagine it's been quite some time I'd
like to think as part of this proposal
that our colleagues in regeneration and
assets would also be considering
repairing that that wall
you don't need planning permission for
that but I think it's part of if we're
talking about revolatalizing the eastern
end of Sudbury and we're creating this
beautiful new access if you approve it
then I think one of the things we need
to look at is repairing that section of
wall to
finish the job off because it is
particularly unsightly
looking in cornard Road there is
a strange section of Road there's a
mixture of garages and the college use
and other uses there's actually a
beautiful building here that's boarded
up
and what I'm hoping is that if this were
to get permission we would start to
revitalize this end of of Sudbury and
that might encourage other buildings to
get to get improved
again a series of shots around that
roundabout what I would say is going
yesterday I was incredibly impressed by
how busy the park was went right through
the park
um all ages
all sorts of activities
Ingram's well row was was parked solidly
it was so popular that that road was was
full also it's been a little while since
I've been to Sudbury but actually
Sudbury itself was also incredibly busy
it actually looked um very uh
flourishing and she's good to see I
don't know whether a representatives
from Sudbury have a different view but
the day I went it was magnificent
in terms of the appearance here we've
got some shots of the world I will get
closer I imagine we might have some
problems so what I've done here is show
the the new wall in the entrance minus
any development that might be happening
in the in the background because what
you're looking at here is simply an
entrance to a wall you're not looking at
any other proposals not judging this on
the merits of the entrance proposal and
the details I'm about to show you
so we look at that end of the
The Proposal
which to help you councilor beer and
others that's the section we're looking
at so where the wall cranks out
we're looking at that end of the
site
and now you can see the
the two steps
approaches one on the far left one in
the middle and the ramp actually zigzags
right left right and Crosses
the path
but where it crosses that's actually the
step stop and there's a level platform
so what the designers have cleverly
integrated is the ramp
and the footpath
so that there's a whole series of ways
you can work your way up to the entrance
none of which is to the disadvantage of
anyone who might have mobility issues
so there's the ramp
there's the central
let's call it the staircase
and there's the other stepped staircase
and they intertwined
in closer detail
you can simply walk straight up the
steps from that point across and into
the main entrance
you can work across on the ramps and end
up at the main entrance
or you can start on the ramp and go
straight up the middle
because there's the changing level it
also allows a fantastic opportunity for
tiered landscaping which
having seen the drawings and Prospect is
really quite exciting but before we get
there we have to deal with the issue of
the wall something that councilor beer
raised
you can see a retaining law on that
screen
so that's the blue area and it works its
way up in line with the steps
but I would Express is some concern to
you as the committee that
on the drawing that appears to be
open to interpretation as to what that
is that might be offense
my view is if we're going to create This
Magnificent new entrance the last thing
we want to see on top of that is a close
boarded
fence
so were you minded to Grant permission I
think we should condition that detail so
that we have something that is
more in keeping
with the Magnificent entrance we are
trying to crease that could be a railing
it could be a wall
it could be a combination of both and if
I've done the applicant of disservice
then I apologize but the drawing doesn't
make it clear and I think we need to be
absolutely sure
what that detail is if we're going to be
convinced that it's it's going to be
right for the town
we can do that by condition if you are
so minded again another shot of
the retaining wall
in terms of landscaping
trying to see what's
it's very hard to to see but first thing
is um
bins so that bins are included in this
last thing we want is to create a new
entrance and then have litter everywhere
we've got
I'm sure colors are changing but I just
can't see what's there we are trees
we are losing some trees uh three trees
to accommodate
this entrance but we are getting more
than uh like for like in terms of
compensation in new planting
we're getting planting beds in amongst
the trees and between the ramps as I
said this gives the tiered landscaping
effect
new Hedges that run in a radial
series down from the top
and on the Frontage where at the moment
you've got the grass and some some dried
perennials again
new trees new benches
there are new benches throughout the
entrance as well
new planting
real effort to not only combine improved
access but also to improve the
landscaping and make something really
quite magical about the entrance
so as I say there will be some tree loss
and on that screen you'll notice
three biscuit colored trees they're the
ones that would be removed to
accommodate them the excess everything
else is
is retained they're safe so the majority
of trees that make their presence known
in the views on that corner will remain
and they'll be reinforced as I say with
additional planting the whole way
up that slope and around the corner
at the moment there are no trees on that
corner it's just a perennial planting
and there we see it in
in its totality
in terms of views
I want to explore this in some detail
because I've got quite quite a bit of
time yesterday on site just to re-check
what I thought was the case so that
isn't Peter's Church
and obviously it commands views within
Sudbury Town Center it's magnificent uh
Frontage so
like all Anglican churches you know the
majority it is
oriented on the west east alignment
in order that at the Eastern end the
altar when you were at the altar it
faced Jerusalem so we've it's on the
east west east alignment
from The Market Square you clearly get a
view of the main entrance and into the
the Nave that is the principal view that
is the most magnificent view within the
heart of
Sudbury
and we have the view with the church
sitting right at the Apex of that that
view but what about views from the other
end from the chancell end
and I know that a number of people have
quite understandably thought about
shouldn't the entrance be midway along
that wall rather than on the right hand
side
is putting it on the right hand side
some sort of
arbitrary gesture to accommodate other
development but when you look very
carefully
from these points and we look at those
so there's the view from the island that
sits in front of the chancellor of Saint
Peters
and the thing that strikes me is there's
a huge road sign
encircled in red
that masks the majority of
so there's the back of the sign masks
the majority of the view of that like
whoa and what could I see really clearly
it's that piece and that's where the
entrance will be so in terms of
alignment the entrance will actually sit
in a direct line from the back of the
chancel of some Peters
if we were to put it on the left hand
side
you wouldn't actually be making the
statement you want to make because it
will be hidden behind all sorts of
Street furniture and clutter whereas at
the moment you get a direct line
straight down to what would be the
entrance from the back of the chancellor
looking the other way
so I've taken two shots one from the
central point at the moment where you
cross from the wall to the island
and then one from the entrance
of the proposed entrance back and it's
interesting
that
is
I'll try and con composite view so on
the left you have the view from the
proposed access and you'll see you can
actually see significantly more of the
church I've edited in green there so
doesn't show particularly then you can
actually from the vantage point of the
central island because of the alignment
of the buildings on the north side of
King Street
if you want to get a better view of the
church the best place to stand is
actually where the proposed entrance is
and I I considered it quite carefully
because my natural instinct and
inclination would be to think that there
was a direct line from that central
island to the church but actually the
best viewing angle is where the proposed
entrance is
in both directions
so looking towards the town center and
looking back from it
which made me think perhaps the designer
said Ed
thought incredibly carefully about some
of those
those views let's take a very quick look
at the pool because one of the
news that has arisen is clearly if you
were to
approve items on the agenda there is a
risk
that the existing access would be closed
from
Newton Road so let's take a look at what
that access is at the moment
so here we have a shot through the
security
Gates into what was the old pool and you
see that's been filled in that's tarmac
you can see the old on the left is the
old sign which I think
should be retained in some form that's
the sort of name plate of the old pool
I took a shot over the wall and I'd
assume what's behind that
like more
so that's the filled in swimming pool in
the distance you can see the wall that
fronts um
the road cornard Road King Street and
Newton Road
it is incredibly
unsightly but perhaps you don't see it
because most of it's behind that wall I
had the advantage of being tall and I
could see over most of it you can see
that through the gate in terms of
regeneration that's been sitting there
for a long time in that condition
what we're thinking here is that
the new entrance is will be the main
entrance
but if we were to approve this proposal
I think it is right to for our
colleagues to consider how emergency
vehicles get into the park and I I would
suggest that if members were minded to
approve this
we ought to have either a conditional
informative that says before that a new
entrance is open they have to have
provided emergency access to the the
park it's clearly a an ambulance
wouldn't go up the ramp so the only
other possible
place is is probably the Ingram's well
access so I think as part of this
proposal
we do need to
consider that
or in the event that the Newton Road
access is no longer used at whatever
point that is
so there you can see the entrance at the
moment it's as the main entrance is not
particularly attractive because that's
actually a palisade Security Fence to
the right
I've shown you the Bellevue Park
okay sign that's actually inside behind
the the gates
at the moment you you are not allowed to
cycle through there and you don't take
your dogs in there
there's um the Bellevue Park
Urban sign in amongst the parking space
for Cycles
the other access into the park is
through Ingram's Well Road
and again
it's a formal entrance but it isn't
particularly attractive It's a
combination of
security railing and Gates
it does what it says on the tin it
provides security it can be shut
you can see all the cars parked there it
was incredibly busy
I have no doubt it's a much used and
well-loved facility for the people of
Sudbury and Beyond I suspect
quick look inside the park I'm sure
you've all been there but just for
anyone who hasn't I've just walked in
through the Ingram's well road entrance
and I just took a quick shot around and
you can see I've been looking very
parched
it is rather lovely so this is actually
up at the back of Bellevue house in the
in the garden there
here sorry this is where I've just
walked inside the park from from Ingram
as well
looking across
all sorts of facilities in here for
various ages various types of play
natural play formal play
skate
parks
netball basketball
tennis racquet Sports
it was busy but the majority of people
were either in the play zones themselves
or sitting under the under the trees
significant amounts of money have been
spent in recent years by the Council on
on enhancing the facilities within the
park
but we've always had this issue of how
can we improve the access
and again one last shot just to take
here
and we're back so that's the same shot
again
this is almost a closing shot but what's
also struck me was the effort that's
being put in within the town too
actually make it look beautiful so this
is just an ordinary roundabout the
effort that's gone into the planting
throughout the whole of Sudbury is
is impressive and there's clearly a lot
of pride in the town There's clearly a
lot of effort goes into making it look
it's it's best
and I would argue that revitalizing the
east then with this access and the the
new formal Gateway and the planting is
an adjunct to all the work that's been
going on already to try and lift well I
think that lifts your spirit to be
honest
um but also the Vitality of the the town
so as officers
we are going to be recommending approval
there's a visualization here and you can
that actually shows the entrance but
from that distance literally in the town
and from where you are it's hard to see
but in terms of the
visualization there you have a
a shot
so rather than going in up past the old
pool buildings and
condition they're in you would actually
have this rather
well it's a new Garden actually it's a
new formal garden with a range of
planting
a lot of trees a lot of benches
throughout that so you could stop
halfway up
definitely announces here is the park
and here is the entrance and this is how
proud We Are of it this is the effort
we're putting into
making this something rather special
so we are recommending uh inline as
shown on your agendas that the chief
planning officer it's given delegated
authority to approve
The Proposal
I'll leave that shot on the screen chair
just in case that helps discussion later
that's my presentation thank you thank
you Vincent
huh
is yep
are there any questions for the potato
Allison you yeah
I've noticed that yeah obviously you
were talking about disabled access and
everything
um
but I feel that
um
there's not been a lot of consideration
um especially for the for disabled
people who have to come in cars because
at the moment they can park at Ingram's
Well Road
but
Suffolk highways are looking at having
that as a one-way system and a bus route
up there
so if they do that I should imagine
they'll be putting double yellow lines
on so no one be able to put now to me at
the moment they've got Newton Road
they've got where the disabled people
can park
they'll be able to park there and walk
through the park you've got nothing
there at all
we're we're looking out for disabled
people I think they've got a bit of a
rough end of the the um the deal there
um
and obviously
um the other question really or a
statement or every question well it's a
question on
what what are you going to do about
disabled drivers that I know you're not
meant to be putting the two together
but it does seem to be coming this way
um what are you going to do about
disabled drivers to be able to
um obviously park there and get in there
because I don't think the disabled
access has done enough
[Music]
I can't comment on what may or may not
be in the minds of Suffolk
County Council you have an advantage
over me counselor Owen have probably
been a county councilor as well have
been in with some of the plans we do
have been with us I don't know whether
Ben's up to speed on what may or may not
happen but at the moment Ingram Square
Road is available is well used
uh and um that's where the majority of
people park at the moment in terms of
whether additional parking could be made
available closer to the new entrance in
terms of
um blue badge places that's something I
would have to consider outside of this
meeting because I
you wouldn't have the ability to park
around that Junction around all those
roundabouts so it is something that we
would have to go away and have a
discussion with our colleagues but I
understand the point you're making we're
creating a new entrance and we're
encouraging people to use that or are
you making the entrance itself DDA
compliant let's go and think about how
we can improve access for people that
are either drive there or Taken
there that's something we could do
behind the
scenes
clearly within this proposal there
aren't any
um clear elements that include new
batch parking in the vicinity of the
entrance
but it is something that
if you felt I'm sure you would all feel
that was important something we could
take away and the chief planning officer
could look to see what Arrangements
could be achieved
in closer proximity and it would also
allow the chief planning office to have
discussions with colleagues at Suffolk
County around what are the plans for bus
routes and whatever I don't know whether
this is the moment that Ben would want
to come in or you want to save it
I will say but I think what we may have
to do is ask the applicant
to have a look at this I'm getting a nod
from the applicant so they they will
take it take something on board
um
thank you chair
is that working
um well I went went to Sudbury yesterday
I've got to say I but not at the same
time as things but that was my first
visit to the site because I missed the
previous site inspection
and it was a warm afternoon and there
was lots of Children and Families about
and
um
in court as I crossed corn I had great
difficulty in Crossing Coronado Road
great difficulty
and the most scary bit was traffic
coming off the roundabout up into
cornard Road it was constant and the
speed that they were going at was quite
brightening so my question is I don't
know whether it's to the highways
officer or not
but what actual audit has been made of
the traffic flow and that your pictures
spins there was hardly any traffic on
the road well that's not as it was at
three o'clock in the afternoon
and I'm just concerned about the safety
of people crossing
when cars are coming down Newton Road
and Bellevue Road in volume and
communities of cornard Road
what I want to know is what the highways
Department of well I'd like to ask the
highways Department did they physically
go there and audit it or was it a
desktop exercise which often happens
with highways can I ask that question
The Crossing has been subject to stage
one uh
safety order which is
where a team has been out and
that's just it on one side and produced
a report
so so they've actually physically been
there or at what sort of time
or we've we've been
out to site as well as well as the
independence
team that carries out the safety audit
so my concern as a driver as well people
come around that bend very quickly and
are faced with a red traffic light
that's the bit that concerns me and and
children and families and elderly people
as well crossing the road I I found that
a bit difficult to sort of Imagine
that you're happy with well the the TR
affix signal heads would would have to
have the
forward
visibility which which means that I was
would would have to have a clear view of
them from a specified instance in
accordance with the this the vehicle
speeds there I think it is the speed of
vehicles coming off the main roundabout
and coming down Newton Road
that is the I was amazed at the Speeders
that came around the corner
and I think that should be sort of
considered yeah the the other question
I've got which is probably for you is
about the ingrams
[Music]
um
Ingram's Well Road I had a look at that
as well and as Vince said there was cars
parked all down the left hand side of
that road
but given that
um
the weather that we're having we're into
climate change and a big part like that
could be a fire hazard if we have a lot
of hot summers
could you tell me how a large fire
tender is going to get into the park at
that point
yeah I I agree it's something that that
should be considered as part of the um
and and I
mean emergency access
should be a consideration certainly yeah
it certainly would have been difficult
yesterday
okay thank you chair thank you
councilman
yes thanks very much for the
presentation
I don't know if that was you or me but
something anyway um thanks for the
presentation I'm
I'm struck on my own visit because I
think all of us whether we had a site
visit or not have taken a great deal of
Interest over the years on Bellevue and
the entrance to it and one of the things
that struck me was the the nature of the
existing entrance
um
innate preparation of this application
was a comparison made with it I mean it
was an assessment made of the dangers of
the existing entrance because it struck
me as extremely isolated
um no direct lines of sight from the
outside of the park and no direct lines
of sight from the inside of the park
effectively a tunnel a single woman
perhaps would be completely isolated
from view in either entering or leaving
the park and and it is in fact a little
bit on the gloomy side was that a
consideration in in the design and what
would happen to the existing entrance
under the proposals
with your permissions here I think
that's something we can ask our
representative from
our colleague sister service in terms of
the thoughts that went into the design
you would imagine yes it would have been
a consideration
if I just chip in at the moment the
application does not deal with the uh
Arrangement around that entrance no
necessarily it would change as a result
of the second application
and there is quite a bit of detail
around this I think in paragraph five
5.4 and 5.8 where there is talk of the
improvements needed around the Ingram's
Well Road access point so clearly this
is in Prospect
but the planning application is not
talking to a change because it's not a
planning matter okay thank you
thank you
Harrison bear you have a question uh I
had lots of questions Mr chairman I just
wanted to know they're all relevant
enough I I'm sure they're all relevant
uh but I want to know from you whether
we're putting questions at the moment to
the highways officer because I've got
lots for him
um but uh I assuming that we're putting
questions only at the moment to our
planet officer because I want to support
councilor McCarron on lots of points but
I don't think we've got to that stage
yet I think we're at the stage where if
you ask a question
and the opposite feels he needs help
from our colleague at highways then
we'll ask for it I think if we carry on
on that route then if you have specific
questions for the highway officer handle
that once we finish the questioning of
the presenting officer that's okay well
I've got lots of questions then
um first of all could could I um just
say to the planet officer for instance
they have great respect for you and uh
your your approach to planning and
please don't take it the wrong way my
comments here this morning because
um I.E perhaps there are slightly
different to you to do but I do accept
that you've done your job extremely well
here this morning
um and a point is on the photos
well with a camera my grandchildren can
make a picture look whatever you want it
to look like so those views you sue of
looking at it from the church or from
the new entrance I'm not so sure whether
I agree with you on that but I'd be
quite happy to go out with you
afterwards we'll compare them well yeah
but I I still don't think you're going
to see those views when this first was
muted Mr chairman this came to us that
the entrance was basically going to be
in the center of it which is where I
think it should be
and you've moved it now to the Coronado
roadside
can I first ask is the road there being
widened in any way
because you've got the wall at the
moment
you're coming down you're going to put
in a pedestrian Crossing will the road
across there be made any wider because I
know and I've driven that road for 40
odd years come down there way back in
the late 60s when the one-way system was
introduced I was part of a early one
Sunday morning
and that's where I had to sit and stop
any traffic coming from cornard
um I'm going back a long time there
wasn't much traffic on the Sunday
morning or many cars so and the only
Improvement that's been there is the
concrete roundabouts put in they were
tires when we originally done it
now that is the narrowest point of the
hold of that Coronado road coming along
there thanks for beer I think you've
made your point will you please let the
officer answer the question my question
is well you're almost answering it for
him please please allow him to answer
that I know the answer and that's the
problem
there is no intention to widen roads for
cars the point of this is to make access
for pedestrians safer and easier
so we're putting The Pedestrian above
the car in this uh in this instance
right so you're saying to me then that
as cars come round uh from the Newton
roadside and come round to come into
Coronado Road they can turn in there and
that will be safer as a result of what
you'll propose and putting a pedestrian
Crossing at the narrowest point on that
road because I've stood there
and I've seen buses come around and cars
coming down from Coronado Road have to
stop to allow them to swing around
so how is this maintenance safer they
can hardly get by one usually has to
hold back a bit to let the traffic
through and then they have to creep over
the center line to get their Front Range
um that's highways
we have a I might ask Ben to come in but
my
my answer would be is um councilman
Claremont yesterday trying to Cross
conard Road
in my eyes it must be safer as a
pedestrian to Cross conard Road when you
have the benefit of a controlled
Crossing
rather than trying to dodge between the
buses that you're referring to the
vehicles the cars the lorries
what we're actually doing is making
those Vehicles stop to allow pedestrians
and cyclists to cross at that
point so there will be some
inconvenience to car drivers but that's
the point of having the crossing is to
make it safer for the pedestrians
and my next question is
then that if you have red traffic light
there suddenly stopping traffic how
visual is that going to be seen how is
that going to be placed because if
you're putting it back into cornard Road
a little bit which is what it's true on
one of the plans I would think you're
going to more or less be turned and
before you can see a red light
uh so I maintained it's not safe or
safer
um the other point is that
um
the the wall that that goes along
where the existing Ward is now a new
piece of water why haven't you thought
of putting in a footpath on that side
because if you want to create anything
that's going to be safer put a foot path
all the way along there to Ingram's Well
Road
you'll have ample room further along to
put a pedestrian Crossing with or
without controlled lights and and people
can cross there cyclists could cross
their safer so that's where it would be
safer not where you're proposing it if
there's a place that's the worst you
could put this you have chosen it
that will be a nightmare so can you
answer that about whether you're going
to put a footpath on the side of
the whole of that area would be hard
surfaced
so everything in front of that wall
would actually become part of The
Pedestrian public Realm
so the whole of that corner will be
available to pedestrians
so everything to the left of that purple
shading all the way around it's almost
like a Plaza
a pedestrian Plaza right to the foot of
those stairs
will the footpath go along from this new
existing footpath to Ingram's whale Road
that's really a question to the
applicant
um not not to the opposite you're
talking about what's been decided by
that can I please ask you to stick to
asking him questions on his presentation
I am asking questions on presentation
and the officer referred to
um page 27 of the national planning
policy and where it says that planning
policies and decisions should be aimed
to achieve healthy inclusive and safe
places this is such a safe place that's
what I'm maintaining so my question is
should be the baber who are the
applicants should have offered to have
put a footpath along there and if they
didn't U.S officers should have asked
for that you should have asked for
footpath on that side of the road which
would solve a lot of these problems
because you could have widened the road
and you would get a safer crossing point
if you want to cross them further up
chairman can I just come in there I mean
the planning officers just make a
recommendation based on the application
before them you have the comments and
advice of Highway Authority in the
papers whether you agree or disagree
with you with that that's that's for
your consideration
um the the national planning policy
talking about safe and suitable access
we can all know I think the question of
baber's responsibilities is perhaps a
matter for the applicant to address we
as planning officers are brought before
you the application papers with the
consultation advice that we have and the
recommendation is framed around that
thank you
so you're telling me then that there was
no consultation by our senior offers as
to our planning officers to consider
looking at a footpath on that side of
the road when everybody knows that
you've come out of Sudbury and you've
got a brick wall on your left you've got
no room to avoid oncoming traffic if
they're big and you want to have
pedestrians crossing the road there but
come on it's not logical and if you
haven't asked that question your senior
officers should have done
thank you
is that a question
about answering the question that he
just uh answered
Cameron we've we've made a
recommendation based on what we usually
do with all planning applications which
is consult on the proposal before us
so my question then is
that the senior officers of this Council
who are applying for this planning
application did not ask for a footpath
to put on that side
that yet again is a question to the
applicant who for this favor
I do have an answer
well it will help explain
as Philip said we are judging the
application that's before us but as a
planner what I would say is you have
a perfectly adequate footpath for the
majority of conard road on the other
side
if I'm as a pedestrian want to walk
along cornard Road in a more enjoyable
environment I would take advantage of
being able to access the park walk in a
very safe environment through the park
if my purpose was to get to Ingram's
Well Road rather than walk along
cornard Road the other point is that of
course the wall
there is still a wall behind the trees
at some points along cornard Road there
is an incredibly dense tree line along
cornard road on the side you're
referring to to accommodate a footpath
you would have to remove all that Flora
you would also have to encroach into
land that is currently Park to
facilitate the construction of a
a highway so in many ways that would be
disadvantageous in terms of eroding
parts of the park along that boundary
that would be my answer to the question
as we said that might be a discussion
for a different different Arena it would
be a lot safer thank you
okay so Jason
thanks Joe
um you've said several times we just
judged this on these home merits but you
Sam says in the report and we know that
this is also linked to the next
application that's coming up after this
one
um could you say what bearing we will
have if we reject this either
application and why are we tying the two
together
in terms of this application this is a
freestanding application were you to
approve it
permission would exist and this could be
implemented
without reference to
other proposals how will the funding
operates is not a question for the
planning process our position is is this
an acceptable access and if it is we
Grant planning permission but they've
been tied together in the report
can I just clarify that chairman so the
first application in its outcome is a
material consideration in the second
officers can't predict what committee
will do and therefore if we need to
advise you further at that point in time
we will do but you will understand that
from the papers there is a a working
presumption within the recommendation
that paragraph 99 and the issues
associated with open space are addressed
through this application if committee
choose to do something and then accept
the recommendation and we as officers
will have to advise committee on what if
any consequences there may be from that
at the moment I don't have the crystal
ball that allows me to give you better
advice then we'll let you know once we
hear what you choose to do with this
okay a couple of other questions
um on the disabled access on the ranks
um are we considered wheelchair use I
mean what is the Turning circle on the
um on the ramps
well we'll check with our colleagues but
it is badged as being fully DDA
compliant so even the platforms we've
got four meter wide platforms two meter
wide
two by four meter wide platforms it is
going to be DDA compliant
okay and on the picture you're showing
where there's the swimming pool
relate to the picture you're showing on
the drawing unfortunately I haven't got
control of the that's no I don't mean if
you could point to roughly where it is
oh sorry again
I missed the question because uh where
where is the swimming pool open space in
relation to
the drawing up there
okay
oh on one other questions which
um I know later on a calf is going to be
proposed for the um for the entrance
and they'll be taken into account
deliveries to the calf delivery vehicles
get into
the cafe in this application
yeah the point I was
I was making is you might want to
condition
so that if at any point in time
irrespective of what might happen today
but at any point in time the Newton Road
access is closed for whatever reason and
before that happens
the council must provide alternative
access for emergency vehicles to the
park
so at the moment as the chief planning
officer said
if you were to approve this scheme on
its own van access would remain so the
question of can emergency access
Vehicles taxes that would not be an
issue
but worried to be at some point in the
future you would actually want to be
clear to our colleagues that
before that axis is closed they must
provide alternative emergency service
access to the park
Professor hope
yep thank you
um I think we have to just remember the
current situation of the park and the
access points that allow pedestrians to
enter the park at the current time
those that are there now have been there
for many many years and people do use
the Ingram's well road entrance as long
as as well as the neuter road entrance
um I know the crossing that was recently
put in or has been recently put in at
the neutral Road Garden Street the sort
of Junction Corner which I believe is
improved traffic flow
and help the
traffic through to the center of the
town I don't personally see an issue
with the crossing at the top end of
Corner Road approaching the roundabout
along with councilor beer perhaps not as
long but I've driven around Sudbury 50
odd years and certainly coming and
approach in the roundabout where you go
up corn on Road in my view if you drive
to within the law is not a fast Junction
roundabout and we have to remember that
people that don't drive within the law
take those consequences into their own
hands
um I know the officer's comments about
the Ingram's Well Road access and
Council Owen also mentioned about the
proposed improvements for England as
well Road I think it will be useful
for highways to give us some indication
as to whether there'll be any blue badge
parking in England as well road which
may well answer the disabled
um access point that councilor Owen
mentioned
I also understand that the Ingram's Well
Road the improvements will have eight
foot path the full length of Ingram's
Well Road perhaps you could get a
comment on that because I think you have
to analyze where people are coming from
to enter the park whether they're coming
from new to Road Corner Road girl in
street or from the Town Center we have
several Crossing points that have been
there for many years and I don't know of
any accidents on those Crossing points
that has been used for many many years
which are not controlled whatsoever so I
just see the entrance on Corner Road as
an addition a benefit to enable
pedestrians to enter the park in a much
more safer way than previously has been
they've been able to do
um the other point I was going to
mention is this a question to that it is
because I'd like some reassurance to let
him answer the first two bits
do that actually I would have to defer
to my colleague Ben Chester
for confirmation as to whether Ingram's
Well Road would have blue badge parking
whether there is intention to put a
footway the entire length at the moment
you see people working up a slopey
Verger
at the north at the Northern end of I
think as well
um unfortunately this this isn't
something I have the to eat out of so I
can't advise that at this point
unfortunately but I can speak to
colleagues and get some some further
details if required
thank you I think well Jeff I think what
we do need Clarity on is the English
royal road entrance it must be
conditioned that it has the width and
I'm sure we wouldn't allow this to go
ahead without the correct width or
emergency vehicles and the servicing and
maintainer of the Heartland itself but
we obviously do need because the officer
isn't able to confirm that but we do
need some clarification if that will be
the minimum standard and my last Point
let me answer that one first and then
you come on to your last point
councilor hold it is within your gift as
a committee to suggest a condition that
requires that to happen as part of the
new entrance I'm surprised isn't part of
the application because that should be
really included in that my last point if
I may
um is the Ingram's well road crossing
point which counts and beer I believe
was mentioning earlier from corner bro
for those pedestrians coming from
cornard who want to go up Ingram as well
Road there's no improvement in that
Crossing there's a drop curb there at
the moment
but our highways are the applicant
considering any improvements to that
Crossing in its existence
I think that's something we can
reasonably ask our colleagues from
regeneration that is a perfectly
reasonable point I tried Crossing there
as well so see what they have to say
about future plans and whether it is
include some sort of perhaps
uncontrolled Crossing thank you
it's just for assistance to counselor
hold there is a an approval of details
of the improvements to Ingram's Well
Road access to the park together with
the time scale for The Works listed as
the final condition in the
recommendation on page 39 and obviously
that would depend very much on on how
much we wanted to add to that condition
so it may be that we could address it
that way yeah I thought that might
happen we need to condition the width
right we're just saying that could be
added to within the condition that's all
thank you councilor Dawson
um yes
clarify for me firstly are these these
overall application here with all these
trees
are they
um is there some sort of condition that
they're going to be mature or are these
going to be saplings because when I look
at the aerial view
but it does you know with the building
that is really an awful lot of concrete
there and um you know initially when uh
one of the things you stated quite
clearly which I'll come on has got to be
welcoming Etc but one is walking into uh
what does resemble rather a skate park
and an awful lot of concrete
so I'm just wondering with the
Landscaping
um
you know all these trees some of them
you mentioned were there and some on are
we going to go in and there's going to
are we going to spend a bit more money
and put proper trees in there
good point we do have a condition
requiring further and full details but I
think if it was the view of the
committee that they would want some
instant impact you could actually
indicate that you're you would prefer to
see
um extra heavy
standards in some of those positions
rather than whips because we are
batching this up as as making an
immediate impact well I'm sure the
residents of Sudbury would want to see
instant impact so could we make that a
condition firstly starting for you is
the committee to determine I think
that's yeah yeah and
um
then also if we go to slide 13 if we may
I don't have control over that but I
think somewhere miraculously
we say can we have slide 13
on the screen please it will happen
let's see if we can work backwards
I think we have an answer to that
question
sorry this is um
controlling the
while they're doing that is there any
more questions for the officer councilor
hope yeah just one more the paving
aspect in front of the entrance and
going around the corner of the old
swimming pool and also the visual aspect
of the entrance there's no real detail
as to what that's going to look like I
think it would such an important Gateway
that um again there needs to be some
sort of condition that um whether we
work with local groups but we need to
make sure that if this is approved that
it is in a style and fashion that suits
suffering I wholeheartedly agree and
then on the um recommended conditions we
do include further details of hard
Landscaping you're right no one tarmac
or anything hideous this has got to be
top-notch
you have slide 13 yeah but I don't think
it's this site actually this isn't I'm
I've written down slide 30
to the form as you're going into the
um and I've written down at slide 13.
and that's that's not that doesn't
appear to be this site on the screen
did you just slide 13 of the with the
entrance details yes yes
the drawings yeah can you get slime I I
have no control do you know what number
it is it's just slide 13.
can you just sorry could you just
could whoever find the entrance yeah for
the uh
it might be 31 on your control it's hard
to get your attention at the back
Fiona it might be 31 on your control
board
any more questions without visual aid
yep
Asher Jameson
um
the um and are we I'm trying to clarify
are we still waiting for a emergency
survey and if we are could that have any
bearing on fortunately we have had that
on the table papers forgive me for not
um explaining at the start of my
presentation I was intended from the
table papers it is uh yeah we're
confident that
yes there are bats and yes mitigation is
required and we will condition that to
be appropriate mitigations
apologies for not mentioning that at the
start okay
a permission chair I might have to now
disappear to look at the control board
so that we can find the right slide for
councilor Dawson apologies counselor
Dawson but logistically it might be
better if I just go and point out
I make a suggestion that we carry on
with the presentations while we wait for
that slide to be
Council Dawson
we're going to carry on while yeah I
wanted to make a comparison to slides
can you please leave us alone there's
two slides yeah
so you have to go back again
please can can you take a seat
will wait while they turn sort that out
so they've got access in the meantime
we'll move on to our pres our
Representatives public speakers
um we have from the Town Council as
Ellen Murphy
to address us
you have three minutes to address the
committee thank you
Sudbury Town Council which represents
all voters in Sudbury has opposed this
development from the beginning primarily
because Bellevue Park is a major asset
for Sudbury which could be enhanced
the evaluations in the papers talk of
public benefit but wouldn't a park open
to the general public be more of a
public benefit than creating retirement
homes for a handful of people
there has been no clear explanation as
to why this isn't open space when it has
been recreational space and has never
been a Brownfield space the amount of
open space has been declining with all
the housing developments with and with
much more to come
trees are very old the trees give us
oxygen store carbon stabilize soil but
their retention will be dependent on the
developer to do the right thing humans
trees are being lost due to the to
development Redevelopment and climate
change old trees cannot be replaced
if Bellevue house is retained it will be
hidden behind the development access
will be through
sorry
can I just say something is element to
be talking on this one I'm talking on on
the on the um Churchill Church Hill one
yeah I think I'm I'm not talking on the
entrance I know you've got it that's
right I think they've got it confused I
don't know there's a mistake we've got
another town councilor here
he's about to be talking on the right
being advice it's not being advised to
me that anyone else was talking apart
from
from Murphy I had an email from Jody
Bard to say that councilman Murphy was
speaking but I haven't been we had
informed Jody that Tim would be speaking
on behalf of the entrance that hasn't
been advised to us
well there's obviously a mistake yes it
looks like a I think can I be heard I
think that there's obviously a mistake
been made
um
so the inter this lady is councilor Mrs
Murphy correct and the other the other
speaker is Tim register who's going to
speak on the entrance well I think I
think we just it's the mistakes been
made these things happen if we okay if
if we if we swap I think that's my
advice Chuck yeah I mean I think I think
well well
we're doing that is there any
opportunity to see your two slides you
yeah yes the questions I was coming back
to thank you was uh this is slide 13
which is you referred to um as being
very welcoming recreational entrance and
then on the next slide you showed us
which is the one with the concrete with
the white ghost figures I think that
might be slide 50.
what we don't see here is this doesn't
rather
um Splendid but on your actual
um lettered pictures
um of the area there is no entrance and
my concern is with this is what is it
going to look like the actual as we walk
through the these magnificent wrought
iron gates I suppose for safety or is it
going to be there is nothing there
sorry that detail
is in the drawings let me for our
colleagues at the back it's almost the
last slide that we now need to move to
it's an artist's impression yeah I think
it's 50 51. yes
but this is Slide 15.
[Music]
I'm mine it's 31e where we really get
there
a close-up no no no the one with ghosts
the uh okay they're there this one here
yeah so when that when people walk into
this area yeah
um
uh
you know there's quite what are they
going to be walking through what is this
entrance is it going to be like Halstead
with these rather rather grand entrance
or are we just going to have a sort of
brick wall with a post or I understand
thank you so as you walk up that Central
staircase what you'll be confronted with
pleasantly is
a gate similar to what you would have at
Colchester Park it is a large Gates
on iron or metal pillars with a ornate
railing running either side so is
synonymous on this so this
this is this bit Escape part is this
going to be all open so in the evening
so the people can want I understood that
this bit would have closed access
that would be over on your drawings
you've got a line going around there
um suggesting that that area is closed
off is it not well everything in the
foreground is open there is new lighting
um extensive lighting
uh ground level Ballard lighting and
other lighting
what what sealed the vistories at the
top of that staircase steps you then
have the metalwork railings and gate
with the gate being much higher in a in
a curve so is that gate there is what
it's going to be
your permission
sorry cancer
[Music]
and it's not visible to see
is it the final details
councilman he's making he's on that
drawing there
they're rather beautiful elegant Gates
what we don't want is some sort of
replacement that isn't the attention of
our colleagues but I'm sure they're
happy to confirm their intention but we
have conditioned it so that we get the
we want top quality not Bargain Basement
and my last question is which
attaining War the hundred thousand
hundred fifty thousand pound retaining
wall now if the second phase does not go
through
um that retaining wall how is that going
to
affect
um or will it not affect this area here
that might be something you want to ask
our colleagues when they have the
opportunity to face questions from you
I think I think that's probably a
question for the applicant to describe
so can I just say Council Dawson
one square part of the same Council as
the planning Authority we have a
different hat on than our colleagues we
treat them like any other developer so
when we say you'll have to speak to the
applicant that's because the purpose of
this meeting they're not our colleagues
they're just another applicant
thank you we are going to have a break
for five minutes the governance officer
and the legal office need to confirm
something before we can continue
please just five minutes great
foreign
foreign
thank you
to me
their mistake
we'll make a restart
just to explain the situation
Sudbury Town Council sent us a name at
nominating Ellen Murphy as the person
speaking on their behalf with the
planning applications
We Now find that she's actually here to
talk about the second one which is the
retirement home and the Town Council
have absent if you are so can you
your Tim register who will be speaking
on behalf of the Town Council
and you have three minutes
would you mind just saying publicly that
you're transferring your speaking rights
to Mr register
register to talk on the opening and I
retain the right to talk on
um Churchill thank you thank you very
much very much for allowing this
appreciate it
thank you very much I've got three
minutes you have three minutes
um Sudbury town council's uh position on
Bellevue Park is that we want the whole
of the park opened up this is the
position of all but two councilors who
recuse themselves of answering when all
counselors were requests asked
um
so we don't want a small narrow
entrance on the corner of cornard Road
and Bellevue King Street
we have safety concerns over the
location of the crossing and the fact
that it could extra congest traffic
congestion especially from traffic
leaving the
roundabout and we think it should be set
back
so that at least one car length from The
Junction in order to and this is met by
um local transport note 120 but also
forthcoming I I gather forthcoming
guidance for streets
um
sorry I'm having to Wing this a bit a
little bit because um
it is unclear from the plans whether the
ramps going into the park are wide
enough for two buggies to pass we don't
accept the faulty centimeters uh because
that's a single that's a double buggy
one behind the other we think we have
looked at disability scooters disability
scooters vary in radius for turning
we've seen one with a turning width
minimum of three meters
we would request an equality impact
assessment is carried out on the ramp
and the entrance and also an assessment
to whether it meets little local
transport no 120 because we're not sure
that uh
the current arrangements and design we
have seen actually meet either those
standards
we also suggest an ecological surveys
needs to be carried out in the site
specifically relating to mature trees
and the bat survey the removal of One
Tree concerns us and and we acknowledge
that there has there is concern over
bats on the site and the other the last
concern is what happens if the Churchill
Churchill Living applications
uh do not get permission and this uh
applications gets passed we don't see
the point in building a small narrow
application a small narrow entrance
um when the S width of the site is no
longer restricted by The Churchill
application uh taking up two-thirds of
the whole front of the park
um I think I've covered everything that
Suffolk County Council
raised and are happy to take questions
thank you very much can we have
questions please
questions counselor Owen
what is it
an equality impact assessment assesses
whether people who are in wheelchairs or
a mobility Scooters or cyclists disabled
cyclists of which Sudbury has many uh
what has a fair few
would be able to use the ramp and the
access envisaged via the entrance as as
in the plans to access without
dismounting and having to walk their
bikes I noticed that in the report from
the planning officer it said is it even
visaged that cyclists would have to
Dismount that would quite easily quite
clearly
break an inequality impact assessment
it's an apps I I asked several uh
important people like wheels for
well-being and they all said an equality
impact assessment is should be it should
have been done in the first place
thank you
thanks a beer yes thank you good morning
could you um just confirm to me
um that the amount of traffic that
you've experienced or you've seen or
your colleagues on the Town Council have
referred to on this particular
roundabout come Junction and these
so-called
improvements which I think will just be
a nightmare okay could you just uh I
like that thank you question well I was
a question of you're embellishing with
your own comments which may affect the
answer the man they give you no I'm sure
um thank you Peter uh I I live on Market
Hill and I see this Junction quite
regularly there is a lot of traffic most
of the time between about 7 30 and about
six o'clock in the evening it can get
extremely heavy and some of that is fast
moving but a lot of it is moving at a
snail's pace if uh you don't set back
the Crossing on cornard road I could
easily envisage a lot a vehicle holding
up traffic even more on that roundabout
can I come back and that
um so would you agree with me then that
the uh if the crossing was put where
it's proposed to be put that the towel
backs will be even worse than what we're
experiencing now
it is the position of Subway term
Council that that would be the case yes
thank you
thank you yeah that's true
I just wondered for clarification
effects since I mean this is a cycling
question there's nobody would be
surprised to hear from me but is cycling
actually allowed in Bellevue park
because you indicated that people would
have to Dismount and I've got a feeling
that I think you probably have to anyway
don't you
a currently cycling is not allowed in
the park I noted from the planning
office's report for the committee report
that they are envisaging a psychopath
through the park as part of the leveling
up fund I have no details on that it's
just not my understanding and I sit on
the I've sat on the um the cycle routes
survey that was carried out for baber
but there is provision and your Town
Council comments that a cycle Lane may
be accommodated but have a feeling
that's on the highways is that correct I
mean perhaps officers can help confirm
that and I have no problem but I mean
I'm always very cautious about Cycles in
use of parks because there are enough
wheeled Vehicles it's quite a small area
and Cycles I'm being honest about it
they can be dangerous in in closed
spaces
uh can I just say that the the park
includes a BMX area so the cyclists will
be cycling
that's an enclosed area it's not your
foot ways that's right everybody's
trying to establish there's also a
bikeability training area so that people
on Full full-size Cycles will be cycling
into the park
um we've I'm not sure what the situation
in terms of uh the bylaw burning cycling
in the park is in the future we would
have to take that but currently am I
correct cycling is not allowed within
Bellevue Park absolutely that's all I
wanted to establish thank you very much
thank you
James
hi Tim you mentioned the LTM 120 and I
just wondered what if you knew what the
guidelines were around the rent from the
lt120
uh yes so
um LTM 120 suggests that any path
um specifically for wheeled or Mobility
Vehicles so this will be for cyclists
mobile mobility scooters and wheelchairs
as well as buggies Etc should be two and
a half meters in width ideally three
meters
um
the planning report suggests that there
are they can't do that the two
the two reasons for doing for claiming
that um
sorry I'm just going to have to find uh
is it claims from LTM one to 120 154 in
talk which talks about infrastructure
must be accessible to all but it says
that this includes making reasonable
adjustments to the existing built
environment but since none of the new
entrances currently built it's not a
relevant you can't use that as a
dispensation and then section 161 which
sense that you know you it's unavoidable
to have it as a narrower entrance I
don't I don't
that says but in most cases it is not
unavoidable and exceptions will be read
since baber are building this from
scratch again that dispensation is is
not relevant so the site the the route
the path should be 2.5 meters width at
least
um and probably three meters I am aware
that that would may increase the
gradients within the 22 meter width
entrance that they have to make it even
harder even worse and probably breach
other parts of LTM 120 but this was
baber's choice they had if you take this
um
planning application on its own ignoring
the related planning application from
Churchill then baber could have made
this twice as wide and not had this
problem
and they chose not to
thank you um thank you thank you
is there sorry is there a discover is
there any um
do you know what the thing the lip roles
are regarding the returning of you know
with kind of threat um yes the Turning
Circle should be about two to two point
five
meters in radius but also the radius
must the gap between two ramps as they
come up the radius fare should be around
the same I'm not sure I have because
we've only saw the adjusted plans late
I've been unable to take this to CAD
level to see whether that works and what
the widths and so forth which has taking
it on
um yeah it needs to be properly assessed
and and impact assessment and LTM 120
assessed as well
thanks thank you
any more questions
[Music]
would you like to comments
thinking of the question of radii
well in that case apologies
thank you Mr register thank you
thank you
I will now ask the officer for a
clarification on one point
I won't ask for the drawing that shows
the gradient but what we have is a two
meter ramp
it's a platform and then another section
of two meter ramp so actually
the area within which something can
maneuver is four meters
so
all right platform uh that's that radius
you have four meters to maneuver
thank you Vincent okay
we now have public speakers of as
objectors I have here Laura Knight and
Polly Roger Brown are going to share the
three minutes or or I'll I'll do three
minutes this one three minutes in the
next one
yep
that's fine okay it's fine thank you
two
who's this
so my name is Polly Roger Brown yeah I
have three you have three minutes yeah
presenting the Bell View Action Group
um please bear in mind that I wrote this
before the planning officer's
presentation so some of it may already
be
irrelevant however
we are requesting that the planning
committee
defer this application until the
committee members are provided with the
necessary information to be able to make
a decision on this planning application
if this cannot be deferred then we
request a refusal
we do not understand why the planning
officers report insists that this
application is approved in order to
mitigate the issues with the Churchill
application when these are separate
applications and must be considered on
their own merits
and the engine site is planned to be
built on existing open space
there are continued concerns about
disabled access and the design remains
non-compliant with LT ltn 1 20. we we
have advised like subway Town Council
that an equality impact assessment
should have been undertaken before this
planning application is debated
this remains outstanding
we are concerned about the sighting of
the proposed pedestrian Crossing at the
top of cornard Road
which will further snarl up the traffic
and encourage idling engine engines at
Bellevue Junction which is already
frequently gridlocked and a traffic hot
spot
with reference to the location of the
new entrance we are concerned that it
has little or no safe connectivity with
Subway Town Center
reaching it from the market Hill the
train station or King Street all
involved crossing a number of very busy
roads some without Crossings or traffic
lights
in 2015 favor
produced a report that suggests that
fully opening up the front of the park
to King Street would attract visitors to
Sudbury this is what we and Subway tank
Council have been advocating for over
the years
this new entrance does not open up the
park to King Street and visitors the
Sudbury will scarcely see it from the
Town Center
we fail to understand when if baber has
budgeted two million pounds in their
Capital program for Bellevue entrance
and improvements why this sum could not
have been used to open up the park as
detailed above
a significant concern has been raised in
the structural engineering report but
cornard Road Corner could collapse on
excavation the risk of a collapsing wall
seems an expensive and unnecessary risk
and strengthens our opinion that the new
entrance is badly cited
the entrance plans
include a significant removal of mature
trees in favor of multiple saplings
which do not have the same impact
visually or physically
finally regarding biodiversity and
ecological issues a favors ecological
consultant
had a whole had a holding ejection
stating that they are not satisfied that
sufficient ecological information is
available for determination and have
advised that the presence of or
otherwise a protected species must be
established before planning permissions
is granted a decision without sufficient
information would contravene para 179
okay thank you thank you very much for
three minutes as well okay
thank you very much
any questions for the speaker
answer Owen
okay
um you've mentioned a potential
collapsing of the war what are you
referring to
um that is that that comes from the
structural engineering report which was
uh submitted with the planning
application
so I took it off Babe's planning portal
I've read it anyway but I've referred to
it when I was writing this
um
I mean that
that's pretty much a direct quote from
what he said
so everyone here is able to look at that
it's actually part of one of the
documents that was posted for the
planning application okay
you're on the front could we have some
clarification on that Structural
Engineering report from officers I
wonder
come back they're going to look it up
and come back thank you very much nice
to be here
thank you Mr chairman
um
good morning
um the wall that you're referring to
um I was under the impression there's
some High faulties
um cables along there uh is that correct
or do you know anything about it I don't
know anything about it because they used
to have signs on that wall saying high
voltage
do we know anything about that then
I wondered if that's what the lady was
referring to thank you
yeah I was referring to the structural
engineers report basically so that that
that's a matter of public yeah again
it's possibly that one's for the
applicant yeah okay you need to know
cancer Osborne
thank you Mr chairman I can help
councilor be on this one there are high
voltage cables and that's why the wall
was never put up back as it was all
those years ago and it's a few years I'm
going to assure you thank you thank you
the time
any more questions
no thank you very much
oh so hang on moments it's not it's not
so much for the for this speaker I'm
afraid it's a rising out of the point
okay well thank you very much sorry oh
sorry Polly
good one
given the constraint that have been set
for this particular application yeah
given the choice would you prefer
nothing to be done
or for this access to be done are you
talking about
yeah
well our
clamping up the front of Bellevue Park I
agree yeah right but if you can't do
that
well actually although we discussed the
we believe that that's to be a better
option than the sighting of this new
entrance thank you okay
thank you yeah thank you very much thank
you
sorry the
Peter didn't hear the answer I didn't
hear the answer I wasn't clear either I
think I think the answer the lady gave
was that she would prefer
that she fought the existing entrance
was preferable to this application yeah
right
moving on
we have the applicant represented by Lee
carvelle
and Lee I understand you have some
support that you're
thank you um so with me today I've got
Chia um Kamai from the land landscape
architect department at HBS architects
who have worked with the council in
design of the entrance okay you now have
three minutes to address the committee
thank you so this application launched
since 2nd of March provides for the
creation of an entirely new entrance to
Bellevue park it is designed to improve
access from unconnected activity to
Sudbury town center and to create
enhanced visual aspects or approaches to
the park including from Hamilton Road
quarter regeneration area the
application has been prepared by HBS and
cheese here today if needed Bellevue
Park is a much love space within the
heart of the town and is often a motive
topic for those living and brought up in
the local area who have both deep
attachment to the Park's history and its
future the council's periodic public
engagements both specifically on the
park improvements most recently October
November 21 and why the program
engagement with stakeholders have
consistently supported improvements to
the park its entrance and connectivity
to the town these issues for improvement
have been taken into account through the
development of the proposals we're
presenting today our Park active
engagement activity attracted around 190
visitors over two days and a wide range
of discussions were had just not on the
park entrance in isolation but on wider
improvements including direct dialogue
with some of the harder to reach younger
age groups that use the park and there
is now a five-year phase plan for
improvement to the park including play
and activity enhancements
the new accessible entrance is not just
an active travel infrastructure
Improvement it has been designed as
flexible public realm and integrated
access to for all and the significant
connectivity
design elements have been designed with
flexibility and accessible use in mind
and to deal with or what deal with the
considerable constraints of levels
difference and the other site
constraints have been picked up today
already
stakeholder work includes the Sudbury
Society Heritage and Town Council
representation and design future Design
Elements will still include studs and
reaches to prevent skateboard use which
has again been mentioned today 73 of
those responding to park engagement
agree that an improved accessible Park
will increase usage by visitors and the
community alike and it's important to
note that very recent wayfinding review
evidence reinforces the fact that the
park has very poor visibility and
accessibility to visitors of the Town
despite central location further
improvements will come forward later
this year as part of the cafe and
surrounding area improvements including
for pedestrians and cycling this is part
of a wider Vision program and this also
does link into improvements at Ingram's
Well Road Junction improvements which
went forward with leveling upfront
application we understand from highways
colleagues that blue badge parking will
be incorporated and also changes to
signage to allow the existing entrance
which is already fit for
um large Vehicles as an emergency access
to be even clearer this is one of the
first tangible and visible Investments
um in this part of Sudbury for a
considerable amount of time and will
benefit The Wider Park more generally
but it's also funding a creative public
art coordinator role to engage with the
community to improve this area of the of
the Town including the wall and the
roundabout and art
artistic mural to the entrance to um
thank you your time is up thank you
thank you very much
you just wait there
question questions counselor
thank you Mr chairman
um good morning Lou
um first of all uh I do have great
respect for your viewers but on this
particular issue I think haven't had to
challenge you and disagree
um but that aside
um can you tell us why is the applicant
you didn't
um consider putting a footpath on the
opposite side to where the footpath is
now this would have improved the
situation because you've widened the
road and made it safer which is what you
all say this is meant to be doing and
that if the footpath went along on that
side it could connect up with the cycle
path where they're encouraged to
dismantle or go onto the road so
first that's my first question I've got
a few thank you
just respond on that
um this does link this is not directly
relevant to this fairly small scheme
application however it has been
discussed as part of the wider Town
Vision improvements and the junction
improvements
um which we're talking to County
colleagues on
um that as the planning case officer
mentioned there is the existing footpath
on the other side of the road including
the cycleway as well
um it will be considered further but
that wrote that whole stretch of wall
along Corner Road is in a variety of
conditions some of it's retained in some
of it's very thick foliage and there's a
there's a considerable amount of
challenge to to doing that that couldn't
be brought forward as part of this
package of work but there's clearly
needs to be improvements this has been
picked up by the case officer to that
area of the of the um cornard road which
will potentially look at whether a
footpath can can be installed there so
Mr chairman you haven't ruled out
putting in a footpath on that sewing did
you say that it could be considered it
can go there are considerable restraints
we use uh to it we need to as I say
there's a lot of um variation in that
wall um that that side of the road and
obviously the height you go straight
onto the highway there's Harris fencing
and there's some retaining structures so
it needs to be looked at as a whole but
it is a potential possibility
um going forward so Mr chairman if we
were minded to refuse this because it
isn't considered safe
could we send it away and could you or
would you then block and put them a
footpath on the other side that that
um The Wider that we've made it quite
clear in the application a lot of The
Wider constraints on the road Network
are not for this application it would be
part of the Town Vision work and link to
Junction work
um and that holistic program that's been
furthered for Sudbury so it can be
considered but I would I would step back
from it being directly linked to this
application I I hear what you're saying
um but at the end of the day if this has
stopped considered safe then uh I think
all those other difficulties that you
would encounter and that's not being
linked because of a B and C are
irrelevant but that's my view
um so it could be done that's the point
um build out
why um why couldn't you take a bit of
that same side
and build out the footpath
that's existent on the opposite side
because that is very narrow and I think
it'd be quite difficult to get to
buggies with uh mothers and children
trying to pass each other on there at
the moment and this will become much
much busier as if this went through so
why why can't we have a build out on
that side push the path out a bit
um well there's this game and the
responses to the consultation period
have been contained within the report
the the actual Crossing itself is
further is subject to further section
276 agreement and this specification
design element we'll look at the width
and what's needed in that visibility as
part of the um
but as it stands that the scheme is as
drawn on the on the on the pictures
thank you but it's clearly felt by the
public that the pedestrian Crossing is
in the wrong place there so that could
be something else that it considered
um I've got others but I'll let you go
to somebody else because I need to find
them Mr chairman please
warningly
um quick few quick quick questions first
how long is this site that went under
consideration for the entrance been in
its current
state
um we believe the the Paul the old pool
site was filled in in about mid 80s
perhaps up to 1987
um so it's been concreted in from that
amount of time same sort of time as the
Kingfisher Leisure Pool opened in
Station Road in excess of 30 years oh
yes like that and it's been covered in
graffiti in some places second question
is the planning officer referred to some
possible conditions regarding the top of
the retaining wall that little red
shaded area
um as to whether what Arrangements would
that be something that could be dealt
with under the planning conditions and
would the would the applicant be
amenable so we believe so yes the the
the main consideration there is the
retaining element so yeah and also how
amenable would the applicant be to a
potential improvements suggested by one
of the members for improvements to
Arrangements at Ingram well Ingram and
Wells Road yes I'll briefly mentioned
there is a four Junction improvements
have gone forward as part of leveling
now of which England's Well Road is one
to facilitate bus improvements as well
that will incorporate
blue badge parking and better access for
vehicles but yes if members feel that's
appropriate okay moving on to this
application of course moving on from
that because I don't want to take too
much of the committee's time but in the
presentation officer gave a reference to
um this wall where a possible path might
be a thing that it's a somewhat dubious
wall we think it means a lot bits of
some conditions other bits are in worse
condition but I do I correctly
understand that improvements to a path
along there would not require any
planning permission is that correct
um
I don't know if officers and your
applicant can help with that I can
answer
um Suffolk County Council is local
Highway Authority and baby district is
local planning Authority have permitted
development rights to do certain certain
Works creation of a footpath or
Improvement could fall within permitted
so it need not form part of a formal
planning application such as this
no fine final question sorry about this
or final questions we've heard about the
potential suggested potential for
um concern about the retaining wall from
this Structural Engineers report can you
actually provide any background and
information to that without looking at
um categorically say but I believe
that's referring to the state that
existing war on the front wall so in
fact and
um so all this works would be
remediation work to and and obviously
the works will be done professionally
and and the temporary structures
installed to minimize any risk of that
and it's good obviously the the
structural engineer report has been
carried out to give you an idea of what
thank you that reference was in fact the
existing wall not the problem I believe
so yes okay if we can have confirmation
of that if it's possible final point is
if we heard about existence of high
voltage cables are there any concerns
that should be applied to those I mean
high voltage cables depends on how high
and where and accessible they are any
thoughts I'm aware there's been some
historic issues there we've obviously
done some surveys and site
investigations and this would all be
properly dealt with including with UK PN
as required as part of the The Works
that follow
thank you chair thank you
next time
obviously
I've made a lot of response from the
people of Sudbury so as the applicant
how often have you met with them for
sort of formal discussion and
consultation so we we obviously covet
did interrupt some of our work but we
try to engage regularly on the whole
program of town Vision work of which
this is a vital component we've did the
last active Park engagement
um on on on the park improvements
including this was October November of
21. we've obviously done the public
exhibition in June which it wasn't
specifically on it because it was live
planning applications but there was
conversations about Bellevue and we did
have the cafe element to follow we give
an update on that of the presentation so
um and we we have had stakeholder groups
looking at particular pieces of this
including Sudbury society as mentioned
in the papers
um so yeah the the the the communication
is is all always look pretty regular on
all of Sudbury stuff as part of our work
thank you thank you chair
question James thank you just a couple
of things are there any plans in place
to deal with anti-social Behavior which
I think is prevalent in the park
um yeah particularly if the next
application gets approved there'll be
people living right on the park I mean
absolutely the council's invested in the
town CCTV Network and there would be
extended cameras as part of the new
entrance which would be monitored as
part of that Network and obviously the
um the um I'll briefly mentioned in the
introduction we're aware of the issues
potentially about risk of skateboarding
and she was already looking at design
features Stars things that make you
quite unattractive for skateboarders to
actually go railing down the um the area
and the disability Forum did actually
feedback on this point which is in the
design and access statement basically
saying that that risk should not
outweigh the benefits that this scheme
would provide for Access for all people
into the park so yes CCTV any
improvements we can add to the design
and generally the the gates and the iron
raw iron railings will be beneficial and
obviously if the other application is
going then there will be more
potentially more people on site later
into the evening as well so would the
gates be looked at night yes we'll be
doing the Locking a public realm team
and uh just you mentioned a little while
ago about there's potentially some blue
badge parking in England's road is that
a definite or um it's part of the I
can't say he's definitely I've had the
conversation with um
the highways officer's colleague who's
been involved with the junction
improvement work and did the
presentations at the public exhibition
uh end of June and there is intention
for blue bass parking to form part of
the improvements to that and turning it
one way including a better exit for
cycling at the top and improve the bus
route as well so yeah I will go back on
that as well and Chase that out but the
intention is there for that to happen
yes okay thanks
that's really new yeah look at my
questions with what's been asked and
what's not been our sort of thing
um
so there are a number a number of ramps
and stuff
and still being considered to ensure
that there will be fully disabled access
that is a real concern of mine
um
that's my first question the bats now
are you meant to do a bat study because
we got
some some table papers and that was for
um item 6B I don't think it's item
success was you meant to have a bat
survey done
um the report does refer to that the
ecology report and I think there's a
condition proposed to address that
there's any clarification I'm a bit
confused because it says 6A which it was
taught about the house and that's 6B so
I was going to get the opposite that's
my my fault counselor that that survey
should not have appeared for the
adventures entrance that's for that the
house the recommendation is that
the chief planning officer be given
delegated authority to approve if that's
how you're minded but first he has to
make sure that from an ecological point
of view he's satisfied but those sorts
of things have been dealt with okay so
should that not be done before we go on
any plan in permission the Eco I can't
even say it the the ecology studies
before planning is done rather than it
being passed on
if I can help you you're not actually
granting Planning Commission today
um the duty on us is to have that in
place for our decision before we make
that decision if we have the that
information to hand
you know from our perspective as usual
to request a delegation to deal with it
so
um from our point of view as officers
that's a matter that can be taken away
exists within professional advice which
we will take consultation advice from
ecologist on all of those things can
come into place and and therefore the
delegation enables the planning
permission to be issued but the decision
today is a resolution on that and is not
the issue of the decision
so you can proceed to hear it today okay
thank you
can I yeah
please respond sorry did you want me to
respond on the first question I think
just please yes so in terms of full
accessibility obviously we've used the
design team
um and we've done um you included
Incorporated both the stakeholder group
work the disability Forum we have done
an equality impact assessment on the
designs as they've gone through which
did prompt actually some some further
improvements
um and the British standards work the
chi and the team at HBS have done and we
have referenced that in the papers
including the um all the required
um uh greatness however there are
constraints of this on the site as we've
talked about so it's been what is
reasonably achievable which is the the
standard
um which we aspire to and the planning
officer has covered some of that in his
report as well
okay
um
um sorry can I do another one
how are deliveries going to get to the
if the calf I know it's not in this one
but then we've got to think a bigger
picture here
um if the if the you get the calf
where how are you going to get the
deliveries to it
so um yeah that will come forward as
part of the cafe application
um later in the year um but the
intention is through Ingram's well and
actually the um the cafe proposal will
look at doing some treatment for the
existing pathway and perhaps why widen
in that and conditions around Service
delivery times for the cafe and
um the designs that we're bringing
forward we're Incorporated turning head
as well for yeah to ensure that so um
and obviously that same route would be
benefit improvements would be beneficial
to emergency access Vehicles as well
just another cheeky one
has the land at the front of the wall
being transferred to Baker because that
was Subway County Council the LA no no
the the highways Authority retain
ownership of land some of the land in
front of their um I think potentially
case any further
improvements or changes to the junction
are needed at any point in time but um
no the the um the red line plans for for
this application and Churchills are
shown on the applications thank you
thank you Carson Dawson
through me yes
um yes could I just ask
um very simply is this exactly
um Lee how it's going to be or are we
sort of led to believe
um there is uh
feasibility to make the area more green
because what I can't quite understand is
um all the residents here there's an
overwhelming
um Demand by everybody the public they
wanted very much more open aspects and
very greed
and this whole thing really
is concrete so do we have the
opportunity to make it a Greener area
which is and I can't understand why
their requests haven't perhaps been
considered here
I think the design and access statement
does speak to the planting that's
intended and certainly has been it's
quite clearly made in the planning
office's report about the um the tiered
structure of the um of the entrance
facilitating so it won't be changed and
this is exactly how it's going to be
that's is that correct
the plant in there will be appropriate
to the to the area and also the
intention is to actually
use that the entrance area to to speak
to the cafe when the cafe and its
materiality and the the biodiversity
planting it's going to accompany
the cafe in there that is a a maybe I'm
not making myself clear
um
excluding all the cafe and all that fact
is that when you walk in here it is
looking don't you think really rather
concretey I mean I I can't see any and
and and the demands has been for it to
be green and more open so at this stage
are we able to change any of that or not
I was led to believe I was told that we
this was it could be changed
um is that not the case is this what
we're going to get well there needs to
be a certain amount of to facilitate the
ramp and the disability requirements
there needs to be a certain amount of
um obviously concrete or but also
sensitive treatment there's a
considerable amount of planting in this
in the entrance
um whether
um that is not really evident is it on
your on your it's to me it's not evident
at all on these slides
um and I don't think it is to the public
either
I I I I just sort of failed to
understand why the
demands haven't perhaps been considered
at this stage
can I through you chair yep the answer
to councilor Dawson's questions the if
the group that have done the Magnificent
um Cloud displays within the town
approached you and said
could we use some of the
hard surf hysteria to put some
additional floral displays would you at
least be willing to consider that as
part of the anglarian bloom or
absolutely yeah well absolutely the the
the the strong the strong Community
groups particularly around the Anglo and
Bloom and there's a fantastic job the
volunteers groups already do in the park
this is actually an enabler for more of
that to happen so absolutely without
question that would be
um
encouraged
Pennsylvania
thank you
um Lee you did um comment uh that you've
done consultation and uh you was aware
of the
um busy Junction Corner Road around
about his uh you commented on the
supermarkets and the Leisure Center
they're all in that area have you taken
on board the fact that this Council has
approved the new hospital site for
Sudbury and great cornard which is
further around behind waitrose that all
that additional traffic will also be
coming down the cornard road
um considerable amounts mainly in motor
cars have you added this in because it's
busy now as you've acknowledged and with
all this other it's going to make this
Junction totally unsafe
um we regularly communicate and work
closely with Suffolk County highways
their comments are clear on this
application
um as part of the the general and
holistic approach to Junction and
Crossing improvements in town Corner
Road is a Strategic Benefit
potentially to Station Road developments
as well and this is about improving
pedestrian
flying around the town this is not just
about
Vehicles however we've done the stage
one road safety audit has been done the
final position of the crossing will be
subject to section 278 agreement between
highways Authority and the applicant and
as you'll see from the highways officer
comments there's no the the principle of
it is is is sound and that it's it's
going to come down to the detail um
there's nowhere from what we've seen
from highways it's no evidence to
suggest that a standalone Crossing will
have a severe impact on the capacity or
the operational efficiency of the
junction and that is what we've had from
County Council
Mr I will take that up with the County
Council officer at the appropriate time
um but am I right I don't believe there
is any monies which are refer to just a
moment ago or improvements to the
cornard road roundabout
the Coronado Road aimed of it there's
nothing in the pipeline for that
anywhere else
no uh the the improvements coming from
down the bottom there are taken up
further down not at the cornered Road
the entrance where the council may be
funding the new Crossing so the district
may be funded in a new Crossing
um yeah but they're subject to further
Works um and obviously costings we've
also commissioned there's no salary to
interrupt there's no monies put aside in
the existing bits that we've got going
on around town to improve on our road
the financing of these projects is their
problem not as as a committee
your great hornad's problem who have to
travel that road every day yeah thank
you we accept that and we accept that
you you'll very much against what's
going to be developed along into the
road but you don't know that but I don't
think that comment is helpful cancel the
whole you had a question yeah Lee um the
consultation process that was taken
place with the public
um what was the feedback generally
um I appreciate the Parkland probably
received a huge amount of support but
particularly the entrance because that's
really what we're debating today what
was the feedback from that consultation
regarding the entrance yeah so we did um
a program exhibition just before covid
and then after covid and the consistent
messages that um basically get on with
new entrance
um for for Sudbury for benefit in the
park
it's it's late so it's difficult to
divorce the entrance from some of the
other feedback which has led to the
five-year Improvement plan which is
available to view on the website but
generally
um the deposit is positive and don't
mentioned the statistic of about 73
would agree that um though improved and
accessible Park entrance will increase
Park usage and the recent way finding
evidence would back that up as well
where
people coming into the town to look at
wayfinding and I think only one person
found Bellevue Park despite its central
location
another question please
um
you mentioned the Ingram as well Road
improvements and we've mentioned I've
mentioned it a couple of times and so
have other members and you mentioned the
leveling up fund but can we be reassured
not that you did reassure Council Irene
that the pro the improvements required
specifically for the access to the park
are not dependent on the leveling up
fund they will be put into place before
the park if this was approved would be
opened
yes we will continue that conversation
with County colleagues they understand
the importance of that location
including to this scheme so we we as far
as we can without being our direct
ownership we wouldn't be able to open up
the park unless it unless it was safe
and had emergency access through
England's Well Road there is a regret
there is already emergency access for
available through that location through
that area the new application will
benefit it further we will look at what
can be done sooner than that anyway in
terms of signage and access for vehicles
but there's a there's a huge variety of
different sized Vehicles come onto the
site through that route already and that
would be an integral part of any
improvements to that area just one last
question chair for me
um
Council Dawson mentioned like the
Aesthetics of the entrance
um I take that is up
for
um change what we've seen today is an
indicative vision of what you see but
that can be changed through the process
if this was approved and views of the
subway Society Etc if you take it into
account to make sure that it is right
and not
just an officer's view absolutely and we
would continue to seek engagement with
the with the groups that already operate
in the park and indeed attracting new
volunteers to to join that and and it's
all part of the anglian bloom and one
wider Town benefiting planting
oh
[Music]
thank you Dave thank you very much
moving on
the ward member has Center apologies
okay
and I'm going to open up the subject for
debate
who wants to kick off Aleister
thank you thank you chair I mean I have
to say I think we've heard most of the
views that might be expressed in debate
expressed in questions already
um and I think every aspect of this
application has been properly covered
without necessarily drawing some firm
conclusions so I'd like to attempt to
try and draw some conclusions from what
we've heard from officers from the
applicant and and from those people who
have got genuine concerns and an
interesting point came up briefly when
somebody said um they had trouble
finding Bellevue Park I had the same
experience myself when I visited a
couple of years ago I think it was
before lockdown when this was being
considered from another basis and I
genuinely couldn't find my way in and
eventually I found my way out of uh of
that I have to say horrible tunnel to
see the site of the former swimming pool
the graffiti the I mean I'm sorry I mean
I honestly genuinely have never been
able to understand since I've watched
looked at this site and examined it from
various aspects how Sudbury has been
able to tolerate having such a blot on
its landscape right in the center no
foot no further than a stone's throw
from grade one listed church and a whole
bunch of grade two listed buildings and
honestly I think it's a horrifying look
for Sudbury and and why nobody would
want to change that or would want a
perfect change but I'm afraid I'm not
sure Perfection is possible now to
provide a pro and I have to say when I
visited Belle View Park struck me as a
beautiful piece of Park work so many
facilities in such a small area I was
genuinely impressed I think Sudbury has
a little gem there
and yet it has this appalling entrance
and and a bit of redundant land if I
honestly can come back to this we'll be
coming back later on I think to the
question of what public open space
actually means but much of this has not
been either public nor open nor space
for 33 years so looking at it across the
board
there are enough conditions in here to
cover nearly every concern that has been
raised by members if during questioning
and during the opinions expressed in
those questions
those conditions are there for the chief
planning officer to
actually Grant the permission we are
just giving the steer as to whether we
think this is a legal proper
location and can be can go ahead
and I just have to say on balance in all
the aspects I think it can I think it
should I think it needs to happen
regardless of the secondary application
if the secondary application were not to
be passed then perhaps if the finance
wouldn't be available to carry out this
work but it occurs to me that if that
were the case then the existence of
planning permission doesn't mean that we
have to go ahead we have a three-year
time limit we could quite easily look
for alternative financing I'm not saying
we should or will do that but I'm saying
these two things can be and are kept
separate
on that basis and I've looked at every
aspect of it the highways Authority I've
cycled around the park in every
particular direction obviously not
through the park I've looked at the
services I've looked at the planning
constraints
um the landscape impacts they can all be
addressed in the conditions and they
should be
there's no flood risk the boundary wall
is necessary I have to say the existing
position is appalling I mean that
boundary wall if it is a risk and other
bits and pieces they need attention and
I don't see any other way of those being
attended attended to without this being
passed so for any progress to be made
for Sudbury and if the Sudbury Visions
to continue I have to say I think this
is a necessary precursor therefore I'd
like to propose the officer
recommendation as it is on the papers
and I'm asking for a second though no I
think we should debate this book
I'm only asking for a second or it's up
to a second okay come forward Adrian
okay are you secondly thank you thank
you Mr chairman I'm uh
I'm going to second that motion out of
the application I think what Alistair
has stated is absolutely true
um I've seen the comments made by
Suffolk Town Council and their concerns
however the comments made by the
planning office on page 37
of the report addresses these concerns
I support this application as both my
heart and my head feels that this is the
right for Sudbury
it will enhance the park and improve its
appearance from the town
this is a one-off opportunity for
Sudbury and I hope that members see the
opportunities this application provides
I'm very happy to second that thank you
Alistair thank you Mr chairman and just
to say to reassure members that debate
will obviously continue until thank you
you're satisfied as chairman there's
been a former every member who wants to
have spoken
cancer of it
Mr chairman on the point of order
Sergeant interrupture Allison have we
heard from the local member because I'm
surprised what I've just heard from a
Sudbury member yes have we heard she
said her apologies she hasn't made any
comments no
thank you
thank you no no you're fine
um I think there should be some debate
on this I mean I'm very surprised that
we've had a proposal so quickly before
we've actually debated it
um I'm I'm very very concerned about the
um
about the Crossing
um I'm very concerned about the church
view as well because living in Sudbury
all my life you will you walk up there
and all you can see the middle bit
and so what we'd be seeing
is the flats if they get done it
wouldn't be the opening
um so so the likes of
um
the likes of the um
of the um Crossing it will be too
dangerous I believe
and
um
where you said about walking on that
roundabout bit in the middle I don't see
many people do that
um there's not many people the only way
of getting around it because the road's
so
would be going across the crossings and
going around that way to the entrance
because the cornard roadway would be too
dangerous
um
I just feel that
um I just feel that this hasn't been
this hasn't been looked at properly
um and I believe that we should refuse
this
um because
of
um the look and it's not where we want
it in the middle
of the Park area
so I believe this should be rejected on
this and I will be rejecting it
thank you
perhaps I hope you were yeah I'd just
like to ask the county highways officer
there's been a lot of talk about the
crossing and members opinion as to
whether it's safe or not safe and as the
highway Authority I'm assuming that they
would not initiate a Crossing unless in
their minds it was safe so could we just
have once and for all of perhaps a
comment from the county
uh officer that this is going to be a
safe Crossing if it was approved
um the the details of
of the crossing would would be great
during a section 278 agreement which
would include include stage two and
stage three roads
site units that would ensure that if it
was designed and can constructed to an
acceptable standard and met all the
relevant um
guidance so we we are satisfied with
people of sing here and that an
acceptable
Crossing can be um
provided
um there are many
um Crossings on the arms of
roundabouts across the county that that
um
I have the potential to make
um motorists have to stop and wait on
the roundabout and um
these these don't cause specific
injection issues to we are satisfied
with with the principle of of a crossing
here
thank you
uh thank you Mr chairman I would just
following on from that last point and
the the County Office of comments
um you said there are many uh Junctions
and situations where this is happening
already but we are going to create one
here
and county in my opinion have not taken
this on board properly I don't think
you've given it due diligence
um when one of your on the site
inspection I think it was your County
officer was present uh even he
um although was following through that
it was safe and what have you was
surprised at the amount of traffic when
we stood there on that particular call
at this damn feelings go off
um haven't said that
um I put it to you that you should go
back and you should re-look at this
seriously because I think you've come up
with the wrong solution the general
public out there that town councilors
the majority of them anyway are anti
this all the local people
can can we come back
the proposal you're just revisiting what
you you said earlier and you're trying
trying to instruct the highways officer
I'm I'm going away and coming back with
it but you what we have in front of us
now is what we have to deal with I'm
well aware and I should I think I'd like
to ask you to to sort of stay within
that
I'm well aware that Mr chairman and uh I
I reiterate that you've got it wrong
um that it is not safe and I have to say
this in debate the others were all
questions uh we as locals who live there
know this you don't
um and listening to some of my
colleagues around this table how they're
prepared to accept this when the bulk of
nearly 20 000 people in Sudbury great
cornard could be affected to go around
these round abouts and and you're just
making matters worse it's not an
improvement it really isn't I'm all in
favor of having a nice entrance built
for Bellevue Park I don't think anybody
in this room would be against that but
to suggest that with your head and heart
you can vote for this because it's safe
it certainly isn't and I appeal to my
colleagues here that they need to take
this on board there is going to be a
fast amount of traffic going and even
there which have heard us all explained
during the course of the morning so I
won't repeat that but you need to take
it on board and seriously you need to
throw this out they need to come back
with a better design because it's in the
wrong place it should be in the center
of where that wall is not on the corner
not on the H and it could have been done
and we've heard from the developers that
they haven't actually spoken much about
putting in footpaths on one side of the
road but it could possibly happen why
didn't they go down that road why wasn't
this part of it it would have been much
safer and I'm sure you would have liked
to footpath along there Mr 30 highways
rather than what we've been given here
this is really a disaster and it's a
disaster for Sudbury and I I really say
to those people that Vote for This it'll
be on your conscience thank you
thank you councilman councilor Jameson
uh thank you chair I do think we've been
asked to agree a lot of this in
principle I mean the crossing is
location is in principle
um the look
of the actual um presentation is now
apparently indicative so we're agree in
the looking principle The Gates have not
been we're agreeing that in principle
the ecological survey is not back yet so
we're happy to grant that in principle
um
despite I mean irrespective of the
safety of the Crossing in that pla in
that location anyone that's been Sudbury
on a Saturday morning when you win the
park people would be visiting the park
you can see that their Junction is the
busiest he's just a nightmare in terms
of traffic and um it'll only get worse
if the crossing is there and there's
councilor beer I mentioned earlier when
the health center is built you're going
to get even more traffic in that
location you've got the Leisure Center
there you've got the waitrose there it
and it's just going to be it's just
going to be gridlock so even despite the
um
location of the the safety
aspects of the crossing being there it's
just it's just the wrong location it's
just going to cause it's going to make
everything worse in Sudbury
in terms of gridlocks Jason cancel
yeah it's interesting how Council via
speaks with 20 000 people
um I think it's an interesting point he
made about the health center I think
that needs to be taken into account
because that will have certainly
increase traffic flow
um but I come back to what I said
earlier that this park has been here for
100 years and people access it in many
different ways and routes cornered row
crossing will not be the only access
point people will still cross from King
Street across onto the front that they
currently do now walk around many people
may not take the crossing across Great
Eastern Road and use the crossing itself
but it is an additional Crossing and
people will still walk through the park
from corner going through Ingram's Well
Road that's what happens now they come
down Corner Road they go through the
park
I'm sorry cancer beer they do I've seen
them yeah it's not guaranteed Nothing in
life is guaranteed I assure you
um but I do find that that we again a
question in the safety of a crossing
that's been a you know the highways
Authority are here to make sure it is
safe this is the second application in
two meetings that we've questioned our
highways and I do think we are getting a
little bit beyond where we should be
going we have to respect our view they
are the authority on this and if they're
saying it's safe it will be safe and
they have to manage our roads they have
to manage the roads around Sudbury and
the county you have to put Faith in them
thank you thank you Nicole just on this
question of the crossing I mean it it
must be patently obvious that no matter
where exactly the entrance the much
acquired entrance to the park is put
because you can't find it up without
that
um there's going to need to be a
crossing somewhere and it's probably
going to have to be around the area
that's specified and it might not be
exactly as in the indicative drawings
but there will need to be a crossing and
I'm speaking from a parish and Village
that um would love to have a Crossing on
a an even I wouldn't say busier road but
it can be very difficult to cross the
a137 so Crossings are hard to come by
and when they're offered I'll always
think we can grab them if we can but
fundamentally that is a relatively minor
point in the overall balance of this
application we are looking at
um
the greater good if you like the overall
effect and yes there are small negatives
they are acknowledged in the report that
the greater position is that sudbury's
Bellevue Park little gem will have the
entrance it deserves and it will be
safer than it I would suggest it
currently is and by no question could it
be described as safe even now
come severe you want to well just on
that point I did suggest The Pedestrian
Crossing could be put in cornard Road
where the cycle
um route uh they expect you to disband
get back onto the road I suggest that
could be put there which is a long way
from The Junction and a wider piece of
road but they'd have to put a footpath
on the other side which is what is
really required thank you so I'm not
just saying we shouldn't have it thank
you I gave options
well gangster advice but you had your
waving your hands around
thank you Jay it's obvious we need to do
something we've needed to do something
for 30 years
what concerns me is that uh when all
we've done all the consultation it's a
case of
would you prefer what we're presenting
to you or
nothing
and naturally people will always choose
to do something something's better than
leaving it as it is and I can understand
that what they haven't been given the
choice of is something different
and this is what concerns me with this
particular application it it's
constrained by other applications that
we haven't yet seen
or haven't yet made a decision on I.E
the residential home and the cafe
if those two applications are refused or
don't come forward
then
why would you put a narrow Park entrance
where it is you wouldn't
it's but
why should we therefore approve it when
we haven't got these other constraints
there are other alternatives to this and
that is to improve the existing
entrance which we could be done at
significantly less money than that we're
forking out for this one
this is a very very expensive Park
entrance and it's going up by 25 or more
over the next few months and will
continue to go up
and after putting extra uh Pavements and
things like that I'm sorry it's just too
expensive
we could spend significantly less money
put a good entrance in in the existing
place and tidy the whole place up but of
course
that's not possible if we're going to
build
the other
um retirement home
so we're caught in this situation what
comes first the cart or the horse
it's you I mean you've heard from the
Town Council if
given the choice they would improve the
current entrance rather than go to all
this palava to deliver something which
is not ideal whatever we say if the
junction isn't safe there is another
crossing a safer Crossing
um
from Newton Road
why should we want to spend all this
money on delivering something that
nobody wants okay
yes
considering this application that's in
front of us the the finances of it are
not relevant to what we're doing in in
terms of planning permission so so
please just stick to to to discussing
the application
well sorry chair but they may not be
important to you but uh
portfolio holder for finance I can
assure you they are significantly
important to me right right councilor
Busby I mean if we had a bottomless pit
of money we could develop all kinds of
things but we haven't we have to do it
within what we can afford
okay
anyway
I hear what everybody says I just think
that um we're likely to approve
something which is going to be a
expensive B not deliver what anybody
wants and see could be totally
inappropriate given the decisions that
we're likely to make on the retirement
home and the cafe it's just
um it's just we shouldn't be making this
decision now or if we do make it it
should be refused okay thank you Council
Davis
thank you um yeah I'm just going to
speak purely on what we've heard today
and from the papers that we've got in
front of us
um it's been a very interesting and
in-depth debate and I've listened both
sides very carefully
um I think all of the questions and
concerns raised have been answered
either by highways or by the officers
and Lee as well presented a very clear
case it is part of the wider vision for
Sudbury it is part of the ongoing Works
in Bellevue and personally I see nothing
that would persuade me not to go with
the officer's recommendation
thank you councilor Dawson
um yes well I appreciate the sentiments
of the shortly consider armed counselors
but um I I concur actually with
councilor Busby I think we we we all
realize something's got to be done here
he's made it quite clear
um the finance but what concerns me what
is uh this business with the crossing
and I think we could have moved it 200
yards down the road but it's more it's
the public the public have made it
really clear what they want we don't
seem to be addressing this and
um so I'm leaning on the side you know
with councilor Busby and my colleague
and much as I want to see this developed
I think there needs to be more
engagement with what they want to see
and we should be listening to the
councilors of Hadley rather than the
councilors of other areas perhaps
extraordinary thank you
Council McLaren thank you chair
um
I think the the
Park plan of the entrance
foreign
but
the constant theme through this is about
the Crossing
that's been the most commented part of
this application
and we
you know as a committer we want to move
things forward is there no way
there can be some
I don't know what I'm going to say but
it's just no way we can sort of discuss
the the sighting of the crossing or
there can be a separate discussion or is
that possible that I rely on the chief
officers too
at the moment you have worked with the
application we have I I I think in terms
of whether that's master or refused
looking again at a possibility about
a Crossing companies probably come along
and from my personal experience Crossing
anyone along that will save yourself
from Pride some harm but a control
Crossing because dodging between the
traffic is very acceptable so I think in
answer your question Mary yes
so it could be reviewed
the site you know nobody's suggesting
there shouldn't be a crossing having
tried to cross that road yesterday they
should be a crossing but
I suppose it's where it's actually been
proposed is the is the exciting a
problem for people
chairman if I just help with that you
have a condition in the recommendation
which is for details of the proposed
pedestrian Crossing it's about Midway
down the list yes which are required to
be submitted I mean the crossing as it
stands is in the public highway so it's
not within the application site to that
extent there is the ability to look up
where that is located now officers will
also tell you well we have a stage one
safety audit on the crossing position
and design as it presently stands
clearly that needs to go further into
design terms and and come forward stage
two and stage three that doesn't rule
out looking again at where that is
located but it does and officers would
start from the position that if it works
and is safe on the evidence technically
that we have we would go with it and I
realize that's a view that gets
different opinion but from our point of
view as officers we can take that away
and can look at that conversation with
County colleagues
um because that is not something there's
a fixed part of the planning application
it is a it is a matter subject to a
condition and it sits outside the
planning application site in the highway
so there is the ability to do that from
our point of view I would say though
that obviously the advice I have from
colleagues on my left and within the
county highways team is that what you
have before you is acceptable but I
recognize that this conversation comes
about because others do not agree on the
committee
so we can take it away
within those terms point of
clarification Mr chairman I want the
chief planning office just said is he
saying that if we were minded to approve
this
um as it is he would go away and then
try and talk to them about
other
movements of where this Crossing could
go or are you saying that we should
defer this or stop this now you go away
and talk about whether this can be done
or not because if it's the first option
uh you're going to get on a PR you could
get an approval and we wouldn't get any
real discussions because they know
they've got it anyway
Jim just to clarify I'm not proposing
deferral the professional advice I have
at the moment accepting that we might
agree to disagree over that is that what
is designed and its position is
acceptable
I hear the debate though and from my
perspective you know this is not
something that sits within the
application design itself it is part of
the public Highway and there is scope to
continue the discussion we are
recommending a condition about the
details and if in discussion with County
Holly colleagues they consider an
alternative location might be preferable
if there's then there are ifs there then
well you know we can explore that and
work that design up but as it stands
my advice to committee is you have a
scheme that has been through safety to
audit stage one and we consider it
acceptable and therefore that's what we
recommend that you proceed on that basis
thank you so I'm sorry Mr chairman uh to
come back on this and and I feel I can
come back on it because the two plan
math has given his professional view
there and it does seem to me that if we
went down that road uh and gave approval
here and went away and talked to them
and they said no we're stuck with this
and that clearly isn't what members or
some members want so I'm sorry I I can't
accept that that's an option thank you
thank you
um looking at this there is so many
conditions on this and where it says
delegated to the chief planning officer
I would like it to come back to
committee
if if you're happy to
to go along with this I think once
they've done this it needs to come back
to the committee rather than the chief
planning officer
thank you for that
thanks to the hopes you uh
I did have my hand up but the question's
been answered to be fair okay thank you
we'll move on then thank you thanks for
the girl okay uh first off I'm not sure
that's legal tattoos to delegate back
from the chief planning officer to bring
it back to committee I'd take legal
advice on that question
um on the question of the 278 that's
what we have section 2784
um we are very fond of perhaps sometimes
not being very polite about highways I
apologize for that but it is a fact
about their life
um the fact of the matter is is we've
had it established that highways are not
going to produce a Crossing that is not
safe it'll certainly be safer than any
existing situation and the final point I
wanted to add was that there's been
suggestion that the public have spoken
the public have spoken a number of ways
in a number of different times not only
through their elected representatives
but through the Sudbury Society who are
broadly in support of The Proposal
although they have concerns about the
proposal of the new Crossing all of
these matters by the way dealt with in
conditions and finally uh lee as the
applicant did give us evidence that in
fact the general public had been overall
in favor of the general concept of the
entrance to Bellevue Park and that was a
public consultation on that specific
question rather than the general so I
have to say that I think we can't just
assume that what we hear today is all
there is to public support
thank you we have a proposal
on the table can I get the chief
planning officer to
or was it as it stands unless somebody
tells me otherwise I've not heard an
amendment to it you know so you're happy
as it stands
as proposed The Proposal as it stands
with the chief planning office no I
don't think we're calling you I don't
think it can be brought back to
committee I think it has to be decided
upon as far as we are capable of but the
whole point about delegated authority is
to have the officers who are technical
experts whether they're doing 278 106 or
dealing with conditions we have to let
them do their job and that's what I'm
prepared to propose exactly as in the
papers thank you
just one thing that planned officer
mentioned was the we would be able
possibly to put condition on the fencing
of the wall so that we're able to uh if
we were able to add a condition so that
we had a suitable fencing now what's
suitable means I'm not quite sure but uh
I'm sure Vince didn't mention that
earlier
I think Mr Isbell could
could encapsulate what he has taken to
be the extras if if the proposer and
second that wish to agree to that then
what you're looking at is an amendment
to the hard Landscaping details
notwithstanding any detail within the
app I took I took the view frankly that
hard Landscaping did cover that issue
and we've heard from the applicant that
they would be more than happy to
consider that so again I don't see any
need but if you want specifically to
include additional fencing on top of the
wall or additional Arrangements on top
of the wall so into that condition I
have no problems with that so such him
what I'd suggest I mean I think the
question came up because there is on one
slide detail which shows what appears to
be a fence on top of a wall for the
avoidance of Doubt what I'd suggest is
we amend the hard Landscaping condition
to include notwithstanding any detail
within the planning application details
any structures or means of enclosure on
any wall should be a subject of
agreement by the LPA so basically
whatever's in the application that
detail needs still to come forward and
be agreed as part of a hard Landscaping
details yep yep I'm happy with that
thank you
I will ask the government's officer when
she's ready
okay thank you and then this that boat
is now in progress
not here isn't no um
going on here
go back in the cross
I did
are you unable to vote I'm I'm able to
vote on the electronic film
um but I'm opposed to this application
so I vote against it thank you very much
I think people might need to log back in
again but I'll take your vote verbally
uh four
and councilor Busby your vote hasn't
come yeah I can't do anything like that
against
[Music]
okay thank you members that's six votes
four and five votes against therefore
that is carried
thank you
I proposed just a quick Comfort break
and we're moving to the next one Roger
quickly we are really running way behind
time
thank you if you want to take a short
lunch now change
okay for another day
oh
I couldn't recommend it we've got things
I might need to plug in
down since
it's nice
we'll make a start wasting no time
um with
Bellevue house an old swimming pool
Newton Road Sudbury I will ask Vincent
Pierce to introduce it to the committee
thank you chair
we're now looking at dc21
06519 which is the site of Bellevue
house in the old swimming pool this is a
proposal for the construction of 41
retirement living apartments for older
people including communal facilities
access car parking
and Associated Landscaping along with
the conversion and restoration of
Bellevue house to form two dwellings
foreign
just to run through
the screen
Sudbury Town Council has recommended
refusal and I'll go through in summary
form their points although the report
does highlight their concerns as does
the fact that you've been able to view
all these online but I think in view of
the nature of this proposal I'll give
you the headlines so Sudbury Town
Council recommend refusal
their position is that they do not
believe this site constitutes Brownfield
land but is actually open spaceland
and therefore development on it would
not be appropriate they believe the site
with the proposal you'll see in a moment
is over developed
and that it will harm the character the
conservation area and neighboring listed
buildings
they feel that there is a lack of car
parking residents
parking within the site
they expressed a number of concerns
around Highway issues and
The Crossing that we looked at earlier
they support concerns expressed by
angling water and Suffolk County Council
floods and water in respect of surface
water disposal but when you read the
report you'll notice that
Suffolk County Council is actually
recommending conditions around drainage
I will go through the drainage strategy
with you as part of the presentation
the Town Council supports the comments
made by the council's arborocultural
Harvester and this relates to a
particular tree I'll show you a bit
later in the presentation t13 which is a
yew tree
which is due to be removed to facilitate
this development
Town Council indicates that they feel a
bat survey is needed and the bat survey
is on your table papers but it's the
item that was included in the previous
item rather than relating to this item
so that was an error on my part
they believe there's no evidence for a
need for retirement living accommodation
[Music]
and they are concerned that this
development would necessitate the
closure of the Newton Road access to
Bellevue Park
is that moving
no
Bellevue Action Group you'll notice on
the table papers there is a significant
amount of documentation submitted
Yesterday by the bill you Action Group
in summary
their concerns relate to loss of open
space
or perceived loss of open space and this
is very similar to the issue raised by
the Town Council Brownfield land or is
it open space
the Action Group believes that what
you're going to see is a poor design not
appropriate in this location
they have their own highways and road
safety concerns
they are concerned about the loss of
access to the park from a Heritage and
Highway point of view
they believe that the bat survey is
required along with other ecological
surveys
they're concerned that the loss of trees
they're also concerned about what they
see as a lack of amenity space for the
residents within the new development
they're concerned about Heritage and
archaeological impacts that will arise
from this development
they don't believe sufficient attention
has been given to the provision of
active travel facilities for residents
and finally
they do not feel that a case has been
made for avoiding
affordable housing contributions by the
applicant
obviously we can drill down that in more
detail and I suspect the Action Group
will will elaborate further
I'm just skipping through those because
you've seen those before so we'll just
cut to the chase just to remind members
this is the extract from the adopted
local plan
the majority
of the application site is within the
gray area
which is the mixed use area there's a
small parcel semi-circular parcel of
land
that is within the designated
Park in terms of the allocation and I'll
I'll illustrate that a little later
so the majority of the site is within
an allocated mixed-use area and
residential development
is for the purpose of this policy part
of a mixed use
on this slide
we try and look in more detail at the
extent to which
The Proposal eats into the park and
again at that distance is pretty
difficult to see but there is a
semi-circular piece effectively it's the
piece next to Bellevue House at the End
of the proposed development of a small
semicircular
area
shown in green
let's skip through those
you can't actually see there you are so
I've highlighted there in Black
the error of
um designated allocated Park that would
be
would have to give way for the
development let's try to do that you can
actually perhaps see it a bit clearer so
it's a parcel there that's 336 square
meters
what I show in yellow is the residual
element of the swimming pool that would
be redeveloped by the retirement living
block that's within the gray mixed use
area
we need to refer to paragraph 99 because
objectives have identified this as in
their view pivotal to the whole
debate and this relates to loss of open
space and quite rightly the government
is
encouraging local planning authorities
not to permit loss of open space unless
there's adequate
recompense and that recompense can be in
open space provided
elsewhere or an improvement to the
facilities within the open space that
that remains but the starting point is
we should not be developing open space
that is particularly Parkland so that at
the nub of the debate will be
is the swimming pool site open space
is it Brownfield previously developed at
the land
and we can't ignore the fact that when
the council
allocated sites within the local plan
it actually said the swimming pool will
be developed for mixed use purposes
it didn't say it should be used as park
or open space the green line is clearly
defined and the majority of it excludes
this site
we've got some facts and figures if we
need to come to those from different
reports some of those you saw this
morning the constraints are the same as
you saw this morning but just so we can
be clear
cross hatched area is the site for the
retirement living again close to a large
cluster of grade two listed buildings
the Conservation Area
and some Peter's Church which is great
great one
clearly
this involves potential harm to Bellevue
House Bellevue house is not listed
statutory listed it is on the local list
and it is a rather fine example of a
large Victorian house it has its own
charm the good thing is that with this
proposal
it includes the retention of Bellevue
house its refurbishment and conversion
into two units
we know the constraints that we
considered this morning in terms of
context
we have a map from 1887 and you can see
Bellevue house nestling in
its own grounds and and Parkland but
what you'll notice on that
map extract from 1887 is development on
the corner
part of that
development
included
you can skip to that
so here we have a
shot of Old Sudbury and the building in
the middle on the left in front of those
trees is the old police station
so that was a three-story building that
occupied that that corner
commanding the position at the back of
that that view in front of Bellevue Park
this is what was Wheeler's Timber yard
red
blue is the police station
Oliver's Brewery
and the railways in green
there was a lot of industrial activity
at that end of Sudbury at the at the
time
there's a shot of the police station
that is the view you now get with the
wall
with Bellevue Park in the old swimming
pool behind it
so there was a substantial three-story
building on that corner
until the 1960s when it was demolished
there's another shot of it wrapping
right around that corner
in terms of Bellevue House Bellevue
house that's on site at the moment is a
replacement for a rather Grand
Georgian mansion house
I think was built in 1877
it's not as fine as the Georgian house
but it is a good example of a large
Victorian house well worth keeping
retaining converting and ensuring that
it it remains because it also
provides the context for the park
and in terms of that semi-circular
Garden that sits behind
Bellevue house so it's an integral part
of the character of the the park and
it's good to see that it's being
retained and restored
we've got some other old Maps here we
just have a quick fly around Bellevue
house it's a view that we don't often
get so that's the front there we have
the back and you'll notice it's on
raised ground
[Music]
sort of commands The View across the
Park some very nice detailing
close lovely brackets and the almost
Venetian style window
well worth keeping
and this is something that the Sudbury
Society has expressed
support for this proposal in that it
will
potentially ensure the future of
Bellevue house
we'll come back to the fact that
Bellevue house is on Rising ground
because that does come in
into the debate in terms of parallels
with what's now being proposed for the
retirement living and there we end with
a shop from the Bellevue Park
we've looked at that this morning that's
the existing entrance to the park from
Newton Road with Bellevue nestling in
the trees
you've seen that shot here's a shot of
the old pool for those that
remember it I clearly don't because I
wasn't a resident at that time but a
number of you may remember this was open
until
um
[Music]
well just before the
Kingfisher Pool opened previously
bathers would would swim in the river
stir at the Croft which was a public
bathing place until there was an
outbreak of
um was it diphtheria so this open pool
was in use for many many years so lots
of people in Sudbury know it clearly
it's now been filled in
we've looked at the difference in levels
earlier between Bellevue house and the
corner we have a six meter difference
which allows a new building
to be dropped into the into the scene so
as not to rise above
the eaves line of the Ridgeline of
Bellevue house and we'll see how that
works again we saw this morning how the
slopes all work
there is a lidar image and
if you look carefully you can actually
see The Ridges where the land Rises
but at that distance you might not catch
it but there are significant changes in
levels almost like terracing within the
landscape
and Bellevue house it's the top of that
terracing of
land there's Bellville house yeah
so we look at layout and access
essentially we're looking at two
components the purple element is the
retention and conversion of Bellevue
house
the area in white is the construction of
a new building to contain 41 retirement
living
Apartments
so that building will hug the corner
between Newton Road and around
essentially L-shaped with Apartments
aligned front and back around the
central
corridor
access will be from Newton Road in the
existing position so
for both the new apartment block and
Bellevue house
so once you're in the site at the yellow
triangle
to get to Bellevue house if you're the
owner or occupier you would go through
the blue or the red gates
some shots there at the moment the
access to Bellevue house is screened off
with hoardings and a Green Gate
and the Top Shot is of the existing
access the one that councilman craw
told us about this morning when he
accessed the sign that's that's what is
the main entrance to the park at the
moment
in terms of parking spaces
you'll notice
I've calculated 16 spaces I need to just
say that the report refers to 17. I can
only find 16. so we've got a cluster of
trying to see that from here 5 7 and 4.
and there's a storage area for mobility
scooters now the reason why we on the
face of it appear to have accepted a
lower
standard of parking is because Churchill
have made a case that the County Council
has accepted
that these particular types of building
within Churchill's portfolio attract car
ownership levels of 0.28
per unit so actually what they're
providing on this scheme is is higher
than they might do on other sites but it
isn't in line with your your own
standards and I suspect at some point
you may want to ask
Ben from Suffolk County Council how
convinced they were by that evidence how
have they based that that reaction on
what have they based it
I think he may refer to other examples
of similar cases of appeals in Suffolk
for this particular type of use and this
particular operator
so let's get to the
appearance
what you have in the screen at the
moment is Bellevue House on the Left
and you have a series of
excuse me
built elements dropping down towards the
roundabout
so on the far right you'll see two Wings
one of which has an apps style roof
which is curved
but the building drops as it literally
both in the ground and in terms of
overall story Heights as it approaches
the roundabout
and this is a deliberate
um
negotiation Point originally
the building was going to be the same
height right the way across so where you
see the central gray roof that would
have gone right to the site Frontage
and what we've tried to do is to stagger
the height of the building
so that it's not one big block on view
from let's say King Street
but it actually steps away and Rises up
the slope
so it isn't as dominating on that that
corner
so we're going to look particularly at
that end of the building
that's what we had originally and you'll
notice it's the same height throughout
and then when you go back it's dropped
quite significantly
so before
after
before after
it's just going on to the next one
this is the view that if you approved it
you would now get essentially from King
Street looking down to what is currently
the wall and you'll see how that has
stepped down towards
Newton Road
each of those blocks is
the middle block is pushed back from the
Block on the right
and the left hand block is pushed back
from the central block so they are
staggered
so again that's broken up the mess of
that building into what appears to be
three smaller buildings even though
inside
the accommodation is all within the one
development
and the building on the left has the
apps roof which is a semi-circular curve
all the way around that corner and on
the right hand side
the edge of the building closest to the
park you'll just need just the steps on
the far right that you
gave delegated authority to the chief
playing officer to deal with that is a
shemford corner so it isn't a
rectangular blocky building each end of
that building is curved and as I say
each individual mess has been
set back to create light and shade and
break down the overall Mass
I'd like you to look particularly at the
area in red because I'm just going to
show you what it was originally in this
application first came in
three
blocky Square
elements
and with the cooperation of the
applicant we've we've got to that point
significantly reduce the scale and mess
on what is the most public face of the
site
so here we have side views so that's the
view against
Bellevue house
I want you to look particularly at roof
lines and this is where the difference
in levels actually works to the
advantage of
helping this development
sit in the landscape because well
there's the roof
let's go back
there will be another slide where I show
you the comparative roof levels
at the moment
the layout everything I'm just going to
quickly run you through the floor plans
for the apartments the retirement living
apartments
we have a combination of one bed units
two bed units and anything in the sort
of pale blue is effectively service area
communal areas and
corridors obviously with the development
of this
size with
um but this occupier there are lifts
there are all sorts of facilities for
occupiers in terms of accommodating
their needs
and essentially the building just goes
up
in a combination of one and two story
units you can see on the far left how
that building is stepped back so it
isn't
rectangular it isn't blocky
it's been cleverly articulated
that's the existing house
and what essentially will happen is
we're skipping through those
it'll be split down broadly down the
middle so there'll be a house on the on
the left which is in green
you'll enter from a new entrance off of
the Newton Road side of the building
and you can
enter the rear Garden through new
French doors windows on the back
the other half of the house becomes a
four bed unit using the existing main
entrance
so they are distinct they don't share
entrances they are effectively a very
simple but effective conversion into two
dwellings causing the minimum of
disruption to the external Fabric and
the internal fabric
and that's effectively so we're looking
at that from Newton Road
and that's effectively well
you wouldn't notice but just to the
right of that blue line is the new
entrance and it's almost um
like a Victorian sun room but that is
a new entrance to the unit on the right
no changes to the window positions on
the on the front all that detailing
remains
a very nice conversion and restoration
which will ensure that Bellevue house
remains in situ and contributes to the
character of the area
and the setting of the park
so the historic context is is kept alive
cross sections
so here we have the the cross sections
I will go a bit closer but what this
shows is that the ridge line of the new
building is no higher than the ridge
line of Bellevue house and it doesn't
compete with the church Saint Peters on
the left
foreign
here we are looking at the the two
buildings from the park
if we just drop that line look
that line has gone below but you'll
notice the height above that red line is
the same
so
they're equal
and that's achieved because of the
difference in levels and the fact that
we dropped the building
on the left hand side
distances between Bellevue house and the
new building are as shown on the screen
so
at the furthest it's 21 meters at the
nearest it's 14.7 meters
this is a view across Newton Road so on
the left we have the new development of
crown building
on the right
we have the proposal
write an element of The Proposal
drainage strategy
the idea is to there'll be little blue
dots moving on there if you can see them
each property will have its own
attenuation tank underground surface
water will be retained
within those areas and released
at Greenfield
runoff levels
so that is perfectly attenuated and
won't contribute to any risk of flooding
what members might want to think about
is with that amount of water potentially
being stored could that be used to
water the Landscaping within the site
I did actually contribute to watering
within the park we've seen currently
just how desperate Landscaping can get
when it gets too dry
it would seem a waste to have that water
and then eventually end up in a pipe and
we could be recycling it and using it
for all sorts of
I think so to that extent we are
suggesting a condition around
Recycling and energy
efficiency in my head I think we could
do some good things with that surface
water in terms of foul water angular
water is satisfied that there's adequate
capacity and the um the network is shown
on that that slide
boundary treatment
this is a an interesting one because
we've explored this morning
the position on there Arrow the position
B we want to be sure that that is either
a wall and railing so this excellent um
detailing at the moment what we don't
have are details but the boundary
between Bellevue house and the park
now what we don't want to see is a
close-boarded fence I suspect any future
occupiers wouldn't want to see a
close-bodied fence so I'm going to come
up with some suggestions we've got a
condition as to how to integrate the
boundary so that it doesn't
presenter fairly ugly face to the park
gives the occupiers plenty of light but
actually sits well within the the park
and my feeling is that that's a
combination of landscaping and ornate
railings
to reinforce what we're trying to
achieve
elsewhere in the park
the rest is a combination of walls and
railings but what I would say is the
boundary between Bellevue house and a
new building on this planet is shown as
being a close-boarded fence
that seems a bit mean when
Bellevue house is a such good quality
and we will argue that a lot of effort
has gone into the design that really
ought to be a war so somewhere in the
conditions I will be suggesting that the
boundary between the two is a wall
rather than a close-bodied fence
in terms of landscape there will be some
loss of trees and in the middle of that
picture in green I've identified the
tree that are aborough cultural officer
in the landscape consultant has
identified as t13 a yew tree
that would be felt to accommodate
this development
the ARB officer has asked it would be
nice if it could be retained but the
building sits right across that so in
those circumstances we would have to say
that we're looking for
compensation planting not one for one
but something far more
extravagant and again as councilor
Dawson mentioned this morning we
wouldn't be looking at some little
spindly
plant it would have to be something
substantial to give it the same impact
within the street scene
the amenity area for the apartments
shown therein light greens that shed
space it wraps around the
entire building
that's because it's communal space that
is perfectly adequate satisfactory but
of course residents have the benefit of
being on the edge of a park
so they have the borrowed amenity of
being able to access the park
and what perhaps we need to look at is
how those residents have access to the
park
it's obviously from a part point of view
we want that boundary to be secure
but it seems a bit mean-spirited if if
residents don't have their have an
access into that
that Park so I was going to suggest we
look at that because anyone in a
Mobility Scooter might want to get in at
that that point but that's something we
can deal with by condition but we want
the site the park to be secure so we
can't have it open 24 hours
a day
this is a strategic Landscaping scheme
and as you might expect It's a
combination of trees shrubs
flower beds grass
Wildflower Meadow the details would come
forward under a separate
condition
so here we have Bellevue house my
thinking was
if you had some sort of ornate railings
possibly with a Gateway feature you
could either plant behind that I.E
within Bellevue house
or
plant in front of it now obviously if we
plant in front of it that's on the
council land
it might be better for the occupiers to
have the planting on the inside than
they have control over it but ornate
railings would definitely
be suitable
in that circumstance
we've got some
visualization so here we are
first visualization
as is
as would be so on the right is the
entrance
to the park and just as previously you
had the old police station around that
corner you actually have built form
creating a
an end stop to the Views to create
the Vista
another shot
down King Street
and here slowly
you start to just see the building in
the corner
this is where perhaps you get the
the strongest View
but do you see how they all step
back
articulated
we've seen those so we know what that is
so
Bellevue house from inside Bellevue Park
and on the left
it's effectively
how you would see the development
because it's stepping down into the
landscape
that's probably the least noticeable
vantage point
section 106 that's all covered in the
committee report
we are recommending approval as set out
in the report subject to a 106 and then
the chief planning officer deals with
conditions
in the event that the section 106 is
suitably completed
and there's a layout plan for discussion
on the screen thank you
thank you Richard I think the chief
panels to add something uh chairman yes
just one point as an amendment to the
section 106 we'd like to include a
requirement for the occupation of the 41
retirement living apartments is to be by
persons over 55 and they're dependent
households chairman
just an Omission from the report thank
you
thank you
questions for for instance
Vince yeah where would be the main
access for emergency vehicles I couldn't
see that on
that screen exactly where the entrance
is now to sorry where the entrance is
now to the park yeah off Newton Road
that's how you would get into this site
so you would come in on that road and
you'd either have access to parking for
the flats which would be on your right
or you'd go straight on through some
gates to Bellevue house
so ambulances fire engines would all use
your fire engines the numbers yes okay
thank you and the second question I've
got is about we've got 41 dwellings of
various kinds
I'd like to understand about the lack of
requests for affordable housing
thank you
I shall definitely look to my
right
so so uh councilman what's the question
about the affordable housing we have we
normally we had that number of
if we were in another application where
it was a development that would listen
to development can't hear you
sorry
in other applications with the number of
dwellings that are involved in this
application we would be asking yes or 35
of affordable housing so the question is
are we applying it or are we not
applying it um in in this instance where
you have an over 55s development
um the evidence base to the Joint local
plan has quite clearly established that
those developments are
effectively not viable within a with any
affordable housing content and that's
the evidence base which takes us to an
approach on viability so we are having
regard to the viability position of this
development and allowing for that in our
recommendation to you and that's kind of
covered in the papers but in essence the
presumption that the jlp is framed
around is that over 55 developments with
any affordable content are not normally
viable and we're taking that as as a
material consideration to this
application it's not the same as the jlp
the jlp is a policy but the evidence
behind the policy takes us to that
conclusion thank you thank you Jeff
thank you Council BuzzFeed so I'm now
affordable contribution and no Sill
uh I think the same applies to sill as
well if
um occupancy is restricted as we would
propose by uh by way of the
um section 106 which I just mentioned
there would be potentially and this is a
subject that has to be explored with
your infrastructure manager
um sill liability in relation to the
conversion of Bellevue house
okay
I'm so sorry we can't hear we didn't
hear any of that about why there's no
affordable housing so so it's in the
papers but effectively the evidence base
for the joint local planners established
that
um over 55's developments such as this
counter Ford uh to contribute uh
affordable housing
um
in accordance with policy what can
afford to come through any and on that
basis that viability argument is the
basis that we're looking at this
application
Professor Johnson
uh so just for clarity So when you say
they cannot afford do you mean
financially or they cannot afford in
terms of
physical building it's it's a viability
element so I mean most viability
calculations presume that a developer is
entitled to a certain level of profit
uh
the evidence we have which is based the
jlp is based on and we're not dealing
with the jlp this is about evidence the
evidence is that these schemes are
across the board not viable with any
affordable content
and that is what we've taken our
approach on
right so I can't afford to put anything
forward at all okay yeah
okay what's their profit margin then
I mean they're multi-million company
what's their profit margin I don't know
what the profit margin that was used to
calculate that evidence for the jlp
um it has in the past been of the order
of between 15 and 20 depending on the
market conditions at the time but as I
say viability calculations are
predicated on a developer being entitled
to some profit in return for the risk of
their development
thank you any more questions
yeah there's been quite a lot of talk
about public open space Vincent referred
to it the papers refer to it and I'd
just like to have a little bit of
explanation of that definition of public
open space both from a planning point of
view and the legal definition from in if
that's possible as to uh where we stand
with our declaration that this is one
type of land and not another type of
land can we get some clarification on
that because I think it's quite crucial
so if you deal with it in the planning
and the legal sense yes I'll try and
start it off and then Ian can sleep up
that was what I was wondering I
apologize if I've got it the wrong way
around so um my learned friend is going
back to the slide pack uh in planning
terms part of this site is designated
um
in your local plan and I'm just going
back to that now as an area of open
space and that's shown green on your
local plan map that goes back to 2006.
little curve yes and in essence a small
corner of this development
effectively I think it goes under the
common room it's a curved shape that
goes under the common room overlaps
and it trans well
um trespasses on that green space
the rest of this site for the purposes
of uh planning is designated as mixed
use it's shaded gray on your local plan
and albeit that there are other
arguments about public open space rights
I'll let
just to pray deal with some of the legal
in that the development plan which was
the subject in its own right back in the
2000s of its own publicity and
consultation clearly defines most of
this site but not all of it as for mixed
use and not public open space there is a
small patient piece of this site which
is within the designated open space
defined in the local plan and as you
know the development plan which
comprises your local plan is the
decision that is the document that we
should refer to for making planning
decisions
now then there's reference to paragraph
99 and you'll have seen some comments in
that in relation to the National
planning policy framework in paragraph
99 has uh three little subsections a b
and c
subsection a requires uh an assessment
to be undertaken but it then is followed
by uh or statement or that the loss
resulting from the proposed development
would be replaced by equivalent or
better provision in terms of quantity
and quality in a suitable location
and this then becomes the material
consideration which your entrance
occasion that you heard previously
becomes material to without that
officers would have to look again at the
quantity and quality of the open space
resulting before concluding that b had
been met
now that said the nppf is a material
consideration your development plan
section 38 6 everything should be in
accordance with the development plan
unless material indicate considerations
indicate otherwise the end ppf is a very
strong policy consideration
it is nonetheless delay material
consideration and our recommendation in
the round taking all of the issues is
that we recommend this development to be
acceptable the open space argument is
one part of that the nppf
assessment of whether the loss of open
space
has been mitigated by equivalence in
quality and quality is a judgment for
you to make we've made a recommendation
we consider it is
there is a definition of open space in
the nppf as well
and at that point I'll hand it on to Mr
Duprey because from our perspective a
lot of the land but not all of it
is mixed use by definition before you do
could I just um come back on that point
you just made so effectively Part B of
para 99
States it should be replaced by
equivalent or better provision in terms
of quantity and quality in a suitable
location so the argument therefore would
be that the permission we've previously
granted has actually increased open
space so that there's a net gain
for open space within the round taking
the two applications together is that is
that the right understanding so in
essence yes you have a material
consideration now in that permission if
that permission is implemented and it
depends upon that and you'll see the
recommendation is contingent on that
coming about if it doesn't come about
then this does not apply if that comes
about then the quantity and quality of
replacement becomes material to ensuring
that you meet the requirement not to
lose open space in paragraph 99b
and that's the permission we have just
approved that's where the litigation
comes in yes you know your conversation
about quantity and quality you can
imagine the quality of space and the
quantity space could spend a long time
debating there's a little bit of
subjectivity here there is there is
quantity is is a physical and yet we can
get that quality is perhaps a specific
debate thank you okay and if if I may
continue thank you I agree with
everything Mr Isabel has just said I
think the only point I need at is I know
um long-standing members of this
committee are familiar you would have
heard me and other people say in this
committee before that land ownership and
the and the duties and responsibilities
that go with it particularly if you're a
council and planning law are separate
matters Mr is spells just explained to
you perfectly if I may say so your
duties as local planning Authority and
how you're being advised with regard to
statutory policies and the mppf
I I am I have carefully read what
everything that the Sudbury Town Council
and the Action Group sent in I've looked
uh mindful of the point they make about
the 1906 Open Spaces act particularly
section 10. I think the only advice I
can give you is that the council is a
single legal entity but it has sometimes
has to wear different hats
and today I'm doing my usual job that I
do all the time of advising the the hat
wearer which is the councilor's local
planning Authority particularly in
committee today
this this is a case where obvious the
counselor is also you've seen our
colleague Mr Carvel wearing the other
another hat of the council as landowner
and an enabler of regeneration so as as
they hope and um
that hat wearer is not legally advised
by me but in this instance by a a very
good outside firm of solicitors and it's
I I don't interfere in that because it's
not my my place to
so I think what really all I can add is
to say that if there are separate legal
issues whereby perhaps the Town Council
and the campaign group The Action Group
hope that they might if they to their
disappointment things go a certain way
today they might challenge land
transactions or operational decisions of
the council that is not generally a
matter for this committee and I I
endorse what Mr espell has said about
the approach you should make this
afternoon
thank you so we're not really required
to be judging on that legal point that
isn't for our job is to discuss the
application itself
as it stands not any subsequent issues
that's my opinion yeah thank you
any more questions
yeah just
looking at their mixed use
are you talking so you're saying that's
Brownfield area as a mixed use or
I want to I want to understand a bit
more about it if you're saying is it
Brownfield area or are you saying it's
mixed use but open space just
so so I I in relation to to the local
plan I wouldn't I wouldn't have a view
on it being Brownfield area because
that's not a term that has any meaning
it's previously developed land I think
we could probably agree that all of this
land is previously developed except for
the open space part which is the green
bit on
the slide designated in the local plan
the mixed use part is probably from what
I can see mostly previously developed
Brownfield if you will
um but it is not open space for the
purposes of paragraph 99 and there is a
definition in the nppf of par of what
open space is
okay nice to be here so thank you Mr
chairman
um could just a bit more clarity on the
answer that you gave councilor Owen
regarding the um
case of our ability because as we all
know it is difficult times and there are
cases where this happens quite a lot but
I was always under the impression that
we if we weren't going to ask for still
or affordable housing aspect of it that
there was some sort of figure that we
knew that they they were going to fall
below and make this unfiable to them if
we insisted on going for the affordable
housing element so you must have that
figure
uh chairman I I don't think I can really
do better than refer to you to the the
description of of these matters in the
report
uh and viability in relation to your
policy cs19 is covered in paragraphs 317
318 319 and three page
sorry I've got a page online 54 hours
old that's fine everybody
so sorry
so so in in essence
we we are drawing on
um
I think if you refer to 319 and 320
they'll get you to the meat and drink of
it German okay but we I'm sorry we must
have some idea because otherwise anybody
could just come along and say well this
is not going to be fireable possible uh
I can't possibly afford to let you have
um three or four affordable homes uh
because I've only got to make x amount
of pounds and I I accept and understand
they have to make a profit but you must
have some sort of bigger idea huh no
specific viability case has been put
forward here and this this assessment is
based following discussion on the
evidence which underpins
the sill uh circumstance and that has
found that older person's accommodation
is unviable with 0 affordable housing
and that has therefore recommended to us
that with this type of development we
seek zero sell and no affordable housing
that's across the piece so that's for
the council okay thank you
it's ridiculous
yes thank you chair uh can I just Vince
can I just have a clarification on page
46
uh of the application under the County
Council responses
we talked about the highway Authority
and we're back to
um
it said it identified that Suffolk
County Council is currently investigated
in the feasibility of further Crossing
facilities in the area
etc etc but it's am I am I right in
thinking that is exactly what we were
discussing in the previous previous
application so it's not an additional
sounded terrible if we're gonna have
another Crossing exactly the same as
this morning same as this morning thank
you very much thank you Jeff thanks for
Busby
uh you're going back to this open space
and multi-use thing here is here really
aren't we we're talking about a small
piece of land whether it's
if it's open space or it's not open
space
it is a very small part
Sudbury is
we've shown that the they're short of
Open Spaces that'd be our own Studies
have shown that
so either in Ipswich
do you know there are four teen at least
twice the size of Bellevue Park 14 and
we're arguing about 35 square meters or
whatever come on we surely we need to
accept that we're well short of open
space in Sudbury
so why are we arguing over a small
little bit
it's just that my cons My worry is that
if you look at all of these various
points here
it looks as though we're favoring an
application from baber as opposed to
what we would do to somebody else do you
not feel that there's a there's an issue
coming forward here
if you looked at the um
the historic the historic building and
the new building next to it if this was
a private application we would be saying
it's an overbearance having that huge
building next to the listed building
we wouldn't allow it and there are a
number of issues like that don't you
feel that there's a concern that we
could be targeted for favoring our own
applications as opposed to somebody
else's
well uh chairman comments of the Sudbury
Society in the papers I think are fairly
clear about some of the pros and cons of
this and there is a judgment about
things but I think their view on the
changes that have taken place are
positive they've got other comments to
say that's that's all within your papers
but I don't quite accept
this is
um partial in the way you're describing
it
okay
moving on
we have the representative for the Town
Council who's going to address us
and this time I've got it right
I
just
okay just hang on one more just one one
I think um that may just have been one
point that just needs to be made is I
know baber District Council was the
applicant for the first application
today I don't think it is for this one
no it's not no it's not
thank you you have three moves
thank you Sudbury Town Council which
represents all voucher
votes I post this stuff
primarily because Bellevue Park is a
major asset for Sudbury which could be
enhanced and opened up to Encompass the
town and the proposed regenerated
Hamilton Road quarter the evaluations in
the papers talk of public benefit but
wouldn't a park open to the general
public be more of a public benefit than
creating retirement homes for a handful
of people
there has been no clear explanation as
to why this isn't open space when it has
been recreational space and has never
been a Brownfield space the amount of
open space has been declining with all
the housing developments and with much
more to come
the trees are very old trees give us
oxygen store carbon stabilized soil but
their retention would be dependent on
the developer numerous trees are being
lost due to development and climate
change old trees cannot be replaced
if Bellevue house is retained it will be
hidden behind the development access
will be through the retirement home car
park where there will be limited private
space any Bellevue house developer would
have the same issue the planning
committee visited the site and the
junction highways may say that they are
happy but this is one of the busiest
Junctions and traffic will be going to
and fro on a very busy roundabout is
this suitable for old disabled people or
even children but they're again building
a block of Flats on a very busy Junction
is not conducive to Healthy Living Well
not in my opinion anyway what is the
detailed evidence that there is a need
for a 41 bedroom private retirement home
on the site and why on this site rather
than other available sites around the
town such as banners we are not aware of
any detailed work carried out within
Sudbury rather than Elsewhere on the
need for development Churchill reports
that there would be 500 000 pounds of
benefit note that the h Profile is 70 to
80 so is it likely that that age group
would provide provide that much benefit
what other Financial benefits no sale
money for Sudbury although there was for
very Saint Edmunds in this application
goes ahead we will lose a big
opportunity to enhance the town with an
amenity for all not just a few please
please when you vote consider what is
best for sudbury's residents visitors
and generations and please ask yourself
how would I vote if Sudbury was my
hometown and finally in the words of
George Bernard Shaw A very wise man we
are made wise not by the Recollections
of our past but by the responsibilities
for our future
and this is you counselors you've got a
responsibility for the future thank you
any questions thank you very much
any questions for the speaker
no thanks
just a couple sorry nope I've let cancer
beer go first oh you go first okay
um first question I have is is how long
has Bellevue house been in its current
state
um for years and years and years since
uh ownership was taken over by baby
District Council certainly for the last
I'd say 15 years not much money has been
spent on it so you know there was a
promise when it um ceased to when we
ceased to be a Borough that money would
be spent on the upkeep of the house and
the park but that never happened and
give you an example of going back six
years for a counselor and myself got
together with very young people in
Sudbury who wanted to enhance the park
they spoke to the residents sorry they
spoke to the users and asked them what
they wanted they said more Ventures and
more dustbins so we got the students
together I paid for the paint we were
going to paint old benches that I found
up at the graveyard I believe was the
graveyard bench and baby District
Council stopped us from putting the
benches in okay thank you
okay that's a very extensive answer
um have I mean
these
there are going to be 41 retirement
properties brought in by this
application as well as two private
houses
um is there a requirement there's a need
for retirement properties surely in
Sudbury yeah
there's no need for any retirement in
Sudbury not at the moment I'm just
bringing people in from outside southern
people the people living in Sudbury seem
to be quite happy where they are there's
quite a few bungalows in fact where I
leave it's all Bungalows
um I think was called the Hollywood
Hills at one time but it's all Bungalows
around there if you go down Christopher
Lane there's Bungalows there's plenty
thank you thank you
um I think you may have to ask that
question I think I will thank you as
well
thanks for the beer thank you Mr
chairman uh or just followed on from
that one I think uh Bungalows would be
much better uh on that side if we had to
have anything
um but that aside
um you'll be quite happy
oh the town pencil and I think the
general public would be quite happy if
the Bellevue house uh was restored and
made more accessible and usable
um but you're not so keen on the large
development of the Churchill site that's
correct I mean if the house was
redeveloped that's great but of course
you haven't got a developer at the
moment because McCain and Abel have
backed out for obvious reasons and it's
that's very sad but we'd be happy for
the house to be sold and renovated and
the money obtained from that sale to be
used for opening up Bellevue it does not
have to be done at once we can do it
piecemeal and that could leave for
improvement at that entrance of this
assistant entrance of course it any
other chaos to the rest of the time
thank you exactly thank you
thank you
because they all seated
development
um extraordinarily well uh would you be
happy because I know they're interested
in them developing obviously uh uh
Bellevue house
I mean did they did they McCabe and they
will speak with you about this no no
I've just read
that's not part of what we're looking
for here I know that they've been
involved before but they've withdrawn so
I I think at this stage you know I think
well be careful with this I
sorry I'm gonna come back on that
I think it's quite an important point
this and can we come back to a later
point on their withdrawal come back
thank you
I I haven't got nothing for Ellen but
okay we asked the highways
and when we get down a bit further into
the description okay that's fine thank
you very much indeed
thank
you
assistant
hmm
we now have Laura Knight I believe who's
going to address us
as an objector
thank you you have three minutes and I
think we've got the right person this
time
Bellevue Action Group with over a
thousand petition signatures are
requesting refusal on the following
grounds the Bellevue site including the
swimming pool site was purchased in 1936
by the mayor of Sudbury can you get a
bit closer to the microscope please pull
it pull it down it should pull towards
you that's it
can you hear me now yes that's better
the Bellevue Action Group with over a
thousand petition signatures are
requesting refusal on the following
grounds the Bellevue site including the
swimming pool site was purchased in 1936
by the mayor of Sudbury IV Sudbury under
an open space trust under the public
health act with a swimming pool being
built in 1939 behind the police station
this key issue of open space has not
been properly considered by the planning
officer in our view and is their view
considered to be previously developed
land but the officer provides zero
evidence for this as there is no
evidence that this swimming pool has
ever been developed on it is not a
Brownfield site and if it was Baba had a
duty to register the land as such
the officer has also linked this
application to the entrance proposal but
these are two separate applications with
two separate applicants and the
fundamentals of this application has to
be considered on its own merits the
report also incorrectly refers to lp30
which the planning inspector had asked
to be deleted
this site has been fully utilized as
recreational space until 2016 when baber
shot the access to the old swimming pool
element labor had previously admitted
understood and maintained a swimming
pool site as publicly accessible open
space because it is open space
open space is not just Green Space or
designated open space and has
definitions both legally under the 1906
open space act and for the parenting
purposes in the mppf
the mppf clearly states that open space
should not be built on unless after
carrying out assessments it's shown to
be Surplus to requirements
labor assessments showed a deficit of
9.84 hectares which is 24 acre deficit
of Park and Recreation open space in
Sudbury
Labor's IDP has also highlighted Sudbury
is a key concern for the deficit of open
space and is asking for more
this planning application should be
refused as it directly contravenes
policy cno3 and more importantly mppf
Para 99a
this application also breaches policy
cs19 and holding objection remains
Churchill are providing no social or
affordable housing with no Financial
contribution towards affordable housing
despite a request by strategic housing
for 1.1 million and they have not
provided any evidence to support as to
why this is a second block of flats to
come forward on the junction with no
contribution being provided the
application does not have any evidence
for local housing need for these private
retirement Flats
despite highways report we're concerned
about the impact of the additional
traffic on the junction the evidence
used by Churchill regarding trip
generation is completely incorrect but
has been accepted without question and
if the application removes access to the
park and no plan has been included for
Access for emergency and maintenance
Vehicles into the park
currently contributing in ppf power 100
and Power 112d
there are still outstanding issues
regarding the bats where no mitigation
strategies have been provided in the
planning application as required by mppf
power 179 and 180 and the holding
objection Still Remains from the
equality Consultants thank you and your
time is up
any questions
thank you
um you said that that sorry you said
there was a petition of a thousand plus
people what was the question asked was
that to save Bellevue house or was this
opposed to any more building on the
um Park area and the car park up there
um the petition was read out earlier on
actually so I think um that was part of
like a a part earlier on but the main
problem is the apartments being built um
the petition focused It's Time on
around that
Mr chairman could the officer read that
out again because I couldn't hear that
at the beginning and that was when we
were first started I know
um we picked it up halfway through but I
think it was the first part where you
gave the figures and the reason thank
you so we received a validated petition
and respect to the application the
petition had a total of 23 verified
signatures previous petition was
received with a total of 249 names
however this was rejected as there were
no signatures included
petition reads as follows
we the undersigned wish to petition
against the development of the former
swimming pool site of Bellevue Park in
Sudbury into a multi-story block 42
living units by church for retirement
living and to the development of
Bellevue house into two private
dwellings by McCabe and Abel neither of
these developments offer affordable
housing which is in chronic short supply
because you adjusted the bike or
something halfway through if I remember
um you are referring to open space which
I think Faber is saying is mixed use
Could you um confirm what definitions
you mean with the open space yeah so I
get two different is
[Music]
an issuing and then where it sort of
crosses over
um the land was purchased in 1936 under
Public Health act uh section 164 of the
public health act 1975 and that imposed
a trust over the entire site that said
that
um the new land owner and which
subsequent baber have to maintain that
land to a good and decent State and
that's one part of it
um the other part is the fact that
there's an mppf has its own definition
and where does where for me there's a
crossover is that well it's twofold one
is relying on allocation regarding open
space
um and the second one is that under
Section 386 which has been referred to
it does say that if you are if your
guard is to be had the development plan
for the purpose of any determination to
be made in accordance with a is not to
be made in accordance with the plan
unless material consideration indicates
otherwise and because mppf 99 is quite
clear that says um this is and it's a
material consideration for me we then
need to look at what is open space under
the mppf as well and that quite clearly
it has its own definition in the open
space which has not been made out yet
and it says that open space is all open
space of public value including not just
land but also areas of water such as
Rivers canals lakes and reservoirs which
offer important opportunity for sport
and Recreation and can act as a visual
immunity
and for me the swimming pool site
I think well I think I think I would
advise you to allow yes
I've never got much more to say if
you're getting I
I think you're entitled to give the full
answers to the question I would I would
advise thank you
I can't remember where I was at you've
just read out the definition
thank you yeah
um so for me if we're looking at this
application and and that's the way we've
taken it is that you the land that we're
talking about here in Arkansas is around
the swimming pool site in particular
that has been recreational use and open
space of public value and asset of
community value and it actually only
ceased to be recreational value in 2016.
and if the
um if you're then looking for material
consideration to override development
plan yes ca03 also it's cno3 is actually
even worse the development policy for
um Babar is development leading to the
loss of important open space
visually important gaps in the street
scene or recreational facilities when
towns will not be permitted so I'd say
actually the mppf goes lighter than the
cno3 and if you're minded to consider
the material considerations then I think
you need to consider the mppf definition
of open space
um hence why our concern is the swimming
pool site is not only is it legal open
space and there have been requirements
under Section 123 which the lawyer has
quite rightly pulled out is a separate
issue
um but there's impacts on the planning
position from our point of view
thank you
I just wonder if the planning officers
and our legal advice I have any comment
to make on on that suggestion or those
suggestions I was seeking some sort of
clarification earlier so so I mean we've
heard for example an act of 36 I don't
know anything about
1936. uh so I don't have a view that
that designates this land as public open
space the nppf contains a definition of
open space it says land which oh let me
just all open all open space of public
value I think there is a fine lawyer's
point in the middle about whether this
land Falls within that and whether there
is or there isn't the nppf is a material
consideration you are not slavishly
obliged to follow it it is a material
consideration that you must weigh up as
you must every other material
consideration reasonable to suggest the
law might have changed since 1936.
a different statutory code as well so
yes okay there's always possibilities in
here you you're looking in relation to
paragraph 99 to
three choices Each of which is one is
alternative to the other so you have to
be quite clear what is expected here
I'll take you back to what I said
earlier
uh and so far as the report goes and
paragraphs
and policy cno3 I did have this
two seconds ago apologies
uh that's
cno303 is policy which states
development leading to the loss of
important open space visually important
gaps in the streets in or recreational
facilities within towns and Villages
would not be permitted so you would have
to have something which qualifies as an
important open space visually important
Gap or Recreational facility within
Townsend Village
that's what would trigger your
consideration of cno3 and on top of that
you also have to consider that the
development plan policy which designates
this as mixed use is the expectation of
a public publicly consulted upon
development plan that was produced and
adopted in 2006 so the expectation at
that time which will have been I imagine
subject to full public consultation was
that mixed use of this land would be the
consequence of that development plan
document so I think we're possibly on on
as often as possibly on different ground
to this night in relation to the
interpretation and application of cno3
and potentially 99b
um
I'll leave it there and that's yeah I I
note paragraph 310 of the report page 53
suggests that cno3 actually contains
less weight than paragraph 99 of the
nppf yeah
which is the question I asked earlier so
I'm just wanting clarification on that
just to consider all the points made
thank you
thanks to James
um just wonder if we'll get some clarity
around the legal position of this
Covenant that Miss Knight mentioned
it's it doesn't have any direct
relevance to a planning decision
it's it's a pro I mean planning law is
is a species of public and
administrative law covenants well there
is
the open space act 1906 section 10 in
fact has this
you use the phrase statutory trust and
that land given to or acquired by
Council for open space but that is for
um
if you look for landlord conveyancing
for the the council in its capacity as
landowner deciding what to do with land
not for the council in its capacities
local planning Authority looking into
planning application and deciding how it
would is this a right use of land in
accordance with planning planning
policies and material considerations
thank you
any more questions
what's the definition of multiple use
then in mixed use mixed use yeah
um so
it's not a question for the for the
object or is it
oh sorry I beg your partner I'm just I'm
following on through Phil is that
because I know Laura has Child Care
problems that she she needs to get away
to so have we all finished questioning
thank you very much for staying
so you want some clarification well yeah
it's just that it hardly seems like
mixed use when we were sticking a 42
block of residential units on it
41 minutes
it seems like
singular used to me but anyway so so if
I can clarify you've got various
policies in which the phrase mixed use
is referred to I can't see it in the
glossary to the to the 2006 local plan
uh and it effectively B2 uses are not
permitted in mixed use areas so we can
be clear about that you may not do those
uh change of use of premises to
retailing and small small scale retail
is permitted
um and in mixed use areas of Sudbury
Town Center residential development will
be permitted particularly where use is
made of vacant or underduced buildings
or residential development will result
in a more appropriate use of land
provided it has no adverse effect on the
viability and vitality of the Town
Center
I think that's as close as I can get you
to a mixed use
okay thank you quite a lot of things
moving on we have
Lisa matthewson as
the agent I believe and you have some
colleagues with you that you
know
okay who will be there to answer any
previous Affair required
fine you have three minutes to adjust
the applicant assault throughout the
application to work with your officers
and consultees to address any concerns
and to be able to assist in the
council's vision for the Regeneration of
this part of Sudbury and improvements to
the park and we are pleased with the
recommendation for approval before you
today the government identifies the
delivery of older persons housing is
critical and this reports development
offers a high quality scheme for older
people on a previously developed site
there is local need for such special
specialist accommodation the Strategic
housing market assessment of 2017
identifies there is an additional
requirement for some
2579 units of specialist older persons
units of accommodation by 2036 in this
housing market area the national
planning practice guidance advisors
local authorities to take a positive
approach to schemes such as this where
there is unmet demand notably in this
census data which was just unveiled in
the previous few weeks this identifies
and babes the population size has
increased by 5.2 percent from 87 700 and
2011 to 92
32021 indeed within this figures there
has been an increase of some 30.1
percent and people aged over 65 years
and over
the applicant is positively responded to
comments from officers at the Sudbury
society and how it's amended the design
to reduce the scale and massing of the
development and better reflect the
lawful distinctive list in Sudbury and
its materials and detailing and massing
the proposal will ensure the restoration
of Bellevue house
much of the Parklands area contained
within the sites will actually be
maintained and landscaped within the
immunity space of the Churchill scheme
and this with the now approved proposals
to the park access and Facilities this
more than offsets the loss of public
space indeed landscaping and the quality
of gardens is very important to
Churchill and the company is indeed won
awards for such schemes the typical
purchase of a unit is a 97 year old
Widow often moved in following a
significant life event such as a fall or
death of a partner it is typically a
needs-based move with existing
properties no longer being suitable the
nature of residents together with this
sustainable property and location such
as this application site reflects in the
lower level of car ownership and use the
proposed level of occupation and parking
reflects survey evidence of retirement
accommodation and existing schemes
nearby including Haverhill this is
supported by the local highways
Authority
the scheme will deliver economic
benefits with the provision of direct
and indirect jobs there will be an
increase in local spending on the High
Street with the majority of residents
being daily basket Shoppers there is
there are significant social benefits
for the new community providing
residents with social and friendly
environments thus reducing the risk of
loneliness and social isolation
The Proposal will provide the
opportunity for residents to downsize
freeing up larger often unoccupied
family homes elsewhere in the market I
would respectfully request that you
support your office recommendation
before you today and approve this
application subjects or conditions
listed by officers and we are also happy
with the occupancy condition that was
just discussed earlier today thank you
for your time
[Music]
it's been explained by the chief
planning officer why you're not going to
give any Financial contribution to
affordable housing yes because it's not
viable for you to do it could you
explain in that case Here Comes you
contribute only 14 500 pounds of the NHS
in your West in Buried from your
development but also 500 000 pounds
there for affordable housing yeah
obviously the schema um and Berry
um was on a different policy basis and a
different local Authority market and
just the requests that came in so on the
base of the affordable housing before
you that has been discussed we have been
reliant on the councils or evidence that
has Justified fully and evidence
throughout
um that affordable housing contribution
for schemes of specialist housing of the
over 55s and cannot viably meet any
affordable housing contribution and
hence why we are happy to accept that
condition because the nature of our
residents who would move in would
obviously be over that age in any event
that's really thank you
um have you done a housing needs survey
been completed and for this type of
property and the next question will be
I'll do two in one
um will you be looking to change the
house plans from what is being presented
today
as the other developer moved through
taken the first point obviously in the
speech that I've just read out to you it
did actually refer back to the housing
needs information that has been put
forward in terms of the requirement for
2579 units of specialist older persons
accommodation which is required in this
house and market area before
2036 and I think the census information
which is obviously just recently been
released at the end of June just
confirms that position has been critical
really at a both a local level and at
the national level also
and my second question yeah just taken
in terms of the second Point
um obviously the application before you
we are the applicant well Churchill or
the applicant for this scheme in terms
of the proposals
um I know that Macaulay John we are
happy to go out to other people
Churchill have indeed developed a
locally listed buildings themselves as
well and we'd be more than happy to to
do so if that was it excited so you can
use them plans and your right to use
them obviously I don't know nothing
about the law like that are you allowed
to use them plans and everything if if
another one if someone else done the
plans or
foreign
by the planning permission uh if if
there are drawings in there that that
he believes he has got copyright too we
will substitute those with their own
before there is a permission granted
there's no issue in that sense but the
plans themselves the proposals are
exactly as they are as two large houses
to be developed that's our plan it's
always been the the the scheme and uh
anything anything else would require a
separate planning permission yeah I was
going to say if that's the scheme before
you know if there was any changes to
that that would have to come back to
yourselves um
that but that's certainly not in this
community scheme of things at the moment
question
um I'm sorry I don't know a lot about
Churchill but
on-site is this is the support for
residents is there a money in terms of
one of the reasons why in fact
um the council's own viability
assessment proves unviable there are a
range of community communal facilities
within the building if you look at the
site plan for instance
um on the ground floor level there is an
honors lounge and there's a small coffee
bar within that and there's a reception
area where there is a large manager
who'll be present during daytime hours
so they have a reception desk if there's
any needs or requirements
um you know that can't be met they would
check up on them and just facilitate the
organization
um of that area so they've got an office
accommodation there is a buggy store as
well outside of when the launch manager
is not there there's like a care alarm
system which is operational 24 hours a
day there's a lift within the building
so there's level access within the
building so um anybody purchasing a
property and can get to the front doors
and without the need to steps as well
obviously the staircase is within the
building as well and there's an external
patio area adjacent to the owner's
Lounge as well and then this community
immunity space which can be enjoyed by
any of the owners and within the
development
um as well and within that and obviously
there's the the car parking in the buggy
store
um as well um externally to that so is
there any facility for
um
relatives to sorry yeah you still
actually missed the one communion
facility that I didn't mention there is
a guest Suite
um within the development which
comprises of two single beds um it's an
ensuite room so somebody can book that
out for relatives that may left further
afield and offerings for instance that
can be booked out
um by the that's one of the the jobs of
the launch manager to maintain that as
well so so yes there is that facility
with it and I just ask another question
thank you
um in terms of
people being independent
and you're talking about communal
facilities including a laundry for
instance is there any opportunity for
residents to drive their washing outside
or is it all done with an internal dryer
or something like that yeah there isn't
a community laundry within this and
people have which have their own
facility so some people may choose to
have a washer dryer for instance or some
people just with the with the dryer so
so that would be done sort of internal
within
um individual Apartments as would be the
case with open back if I
thank you thank you Joe
you were yeah thank you uh if we were
minded to um approve this application
this afternoon how
um uh quickly would you be able to
purchase a site how quickly would you
get a spade in the ground and how
quickly would you get or hope to get the
first
um
um people to uh living in those
properties yeah obviously there's a lot
of work that would need to be done
before times in terms of getting onto
site but you know we've got a number of
conditions and that your officers have
suggested and that we certainly need to
be discharged as well and further
um consultation with your officers on
certain aspects of that in terms of
actually physically completing and
purchasing on the site on it yeah I mean
we we like to move as quickly as we
possibly can we're obviously working in
tandem with the council here and the
works on on the new park entrance are go
hand in hand because obviously the the
new wall that will create the boundary
between the two states has to be created
so we're working very closely with the
Council on that
um you know we obviously won't the point
where contractors are the council want
to point contractors until we've got a
permission but as soon as that simply is
we want to move as quickly as we
possibly can in terms of moving people
in we don't sell off plan that's not
what we do in the retirement sector we
would we at until it's pretty much
completely finished our construction
program is probably 13 months from when
we start there are there abouts and we
would then be moving resident since then
as soon as it was finished no residents
would actually move it until there was a
large manager in place and all of the
communal facilities and were fully
complete Etc as well so but your answer
sounded as though it could take a very
long time before this all gets sorted
that you could get a plan on permission
um if we reminded to approve it but end
up where this goes on for years rather
than months no it certainly we didn't go
on for years obviously planning
conditions and there has to be a
development program for the construction
phase in terms of laying the foundations
and you know building that that that's
quite a typical build period for a
development getting on site obviously
the site's vacant at the moment so
there's nothing to stop in that
commencing street doing we can't go into
commercially sensitive details and too
much too too good a level but we have an
agreement with the council that says
that they have to progress quickly as
well I mean if we buy the site we need
them to then do their work as well so we
We have dealt with the Council on that
and we have a plan as soon as we get
permission
Council of Hope
thank you pick up on Bellevue house
um with your projected time frame for
the development of the retirement living
Flats
put that coincide with the finishing of
the house so that we weren't left with a
new weren't left with a built out
retirement area
and then start development on the house
with the traffic and the Builder
materials going through your finished
site so would they coincide
and secondly there certainly is some
concern that you've lost your
co-developer for the house
and would there be and this is to the
planned officer as well really
any way that we could tie you down for
whatever better phrase to actually
guarantee that the house would be
redeveloped it to two houses and there
isn't a sudden change later on where you
decide to build it into 10 flats or
something so that's another question
could you answer that yeah I'll pick
that up I think it's something obviously
officers have already considered within
the committee report it is down as one
of the and proposed conditions and
looking at that conversion element and
to agree a program and so things would
go hand in hand basically as well and
from Churchill's point of view they
would certainly want that to happen as
well because you wouldn't want to have
construction traffic you know driving
through a development which may be you
know partially occupied at that time so
that's certainly something that
Churchill themselves would want to
ensure happens as well and so hopefully
that provides some comfort on that
element would there be any further
commitment we could obtain to ensure
that that helped two properties and only
two properties
foreign
well clearly the the question of who
does the work is probably a market
question
um we had proposed a condition if you
want to ensure that that is uh even more
water tight you might convert that
condition that you have in your papers
to a section 106 obligation
and that would then uh you then look
back to the developer to ensure that
that program of Works delivers this
relative to the occupancy of uh the
adjacent 41 units and that will be my
approach to this so
Jim the recommendation before you is to
have that as a condition it gives
members confidence we can amend that to
make the condition requiring the
conversion of Bellevue House part of the
section 106 obligation yes
thank you uh yeah thank you very much
for coming along today
um
you've got 41 Flats in the uh retirement
that's correct
properties how many people would you
expect to be able to be accommodated
within those do the average occupancy is
approximately 1.3 persons per unit
yeah okay so about for 50 something
there about yeah okay and we're
obviously you're expecting to be able to
sell or rent these
um where would you expect the um
residents to come from what sort of
in terms of obviously you know we are
here because you know we feel that there
is a need in this area
um as well and that's backed up so
there's a geographic about that
narcissistics we do find you know some
people might have family that live
further afield and things like that but
that's typical you know we can't you
know ascertain about every single person
we'd come in from but yeah the local
region
um effectively for the norm but you do
get some anomalies in that and and
obviously during the process of going
through all this you'll have engaged
with our economic development team on
one hand and on the other hand
separately with the planning department
what engagement have you had with
Community groups
um and uh other interested parties shall
we there has been public consultation
which did occur in two stages in an
Autumn last year and so that
consultation there was an event last
year in Sudbury in the local area and
residents and local groups would have
all been written to in advance of that
as well and Beyond the Expressions
presented to this meeting were there any
other representations that of an
informal nature that you might see from
the community
not that I'm aware okay final question I
apologize for this um but it's a cop
Topic at the subject um will there be
any
um consideration of Energy Efficiency in
the property there is yes and it's quite
typical that we would put PV on the roof
in terms of that in terms of electric
charging points for car parking as well
um in terms of the building of the
internal fabric of the building as well
obviously it will have to comply with
the building regulations as well so in
terms of Energy Efficiency it's
certainly something that's at the
Forefront sure your residents will be
very happy to know that because
obviously they'll get the bills won't
they yes okay yeah well I think that's
one of the benefits of the scheme as
well really
thank you
um yes a couple of questions
um I discussed I don't know if it was
with I think it's with you earlier John
I'm wondering why we had a discussion
about why the because of the Colossal
size of this building
um and you can see from the one across
the road
um the height of it and why the third
floor wasn't built into the ease to
reduce the size which it very easily
could have been done
and it might have meant two less Flats
but that was something
um for you to consider and I'm wondering
why you didn't yeah let's do that
actually the design of the building has
evolved quite considerably since
discussions have been ongoing with um
local Authority offices so sorry it was
direct I think the gentleman who I had
spoken to about this is it you yes uh
but I I deal with land acquisition as
opposed to design planning but the fact
is I have been reasonably close to the
discussions here uh the scheme has been
reduced quite considerably in size as
has been pointed over but it's three
it's three stories plus the top and and
actually is it although this it doesn't
compete with the church in this it's the
same height in fact it does the fact
that it's the same height and those top
Flats
you know they could have been put into
the eaves couldn't they which would have
reduced that whole building by a flip
sorry it could have been reduced by a
whole floor I think obviously the images
that um your officers put on the screen
beforehand in terms of the ridge height
um of the building not competing you
know not being any higher than Bellevue
house and confirmed obviously officers
are happy happy with the the height and
the massing of the building which has
involved considerably over the past
um year or so as well but I think that's
one of the one of the major complaints
of the public and residents was the size
of it
so whilst I'm sure the office is I I
don't know why this wasn't really done
though or considered when you said it
would be so we have reduced the size of
the building no but by putting the top
floor into the ease which you could have
done so we we reduced the burden
considerably since the original designs
in in dialogue with the planets okay and
and this is the scheme that we and in
fact we have lost lost quite a number of
units uh during the process so we have
lost six or seven units since the design
commenced by by Evolution we have lost
67 unionism we've been around 61. so we
have we have reduced it quite
considerably
and uh the other thing I was sort of
like concern me is about the Bell few
now
he works in
McCabe who did an outstanding job on
East house
and would have done on um Bellevue house
now when we sold that property there
were seven pages and I believe you gave
them 27 of legal now what bothers me
about this is can you give an assurance
um it would seem that you didn't really
want to get there were a lot of things
that put in the way to force them
they were never going to be able to
complete this project so my concern is
with this is that you could have had or
you may in the future have this
second phase
it won't mention to be a second
some of this is clearly commercially
sensitive but you've asked the question
we uh absolutely from Churchill's
perspective we must have Bellevue house
completed when we have our 41 units
we've never had any plans to do anything
with Bellevue house other than keep as
it is absolutely not absolutely not
there has never been any other plan if
anybody has suggested otherwise let them
tell us what that was we have never had
any other plan we need to have Bellevue
house finished we will be selling 41
Apartments the investment in our block
of Apartments is Farm far far greater
than the spend will be on Bellevue house
we cannot afford to have it any
condition is in we need it finished and
it's absolutely uh core to our plans the
Bellevue house has refurbished and
completed by the time our apartments are
ready to be sold that's absolutely
imperative to our business
I'm delighted to hear that you never had
any plans to have done anything there
I'm somewhat surprised now would you
then be willing to consider doing the
Bell View prior to the main development
so that that part is completed
um and I think Mr planning offices
that's not really part of this planning
application at this particular stage
we're dealing with with this
um I think Ian you I think it's becoming
a bit
speculative if I may say so well our
chief planning officer will just discuss
this earlier about putting it in the as
part of the S10 six
um well if that's a specific Mr Isabel
sorry he's in conversation Mr Dawson
sorry
um I was talking about doing the
priority Bill View and as part of the
s106 which we agreed earlier yes to
ensure that that does get done in two
properties and maybe that should be done
as a priority prior to the actual
retirement to be sure
that that's completed
um well there are no changes it's for
members to debate and accept if they
wish that to be part of the section 106.
the timing of that is not at the moment
set in the recommendation for you the
condition doesn't specify the timing
ultimately you you would choose that
potentially to be at some point during
development typically developers do
require a return then you might well say
not later than such and such a point in
development would be an approach that
you see on other other applications so
the conversion of Bellevue has to have
taken place or to have commenced not
later than xdate is is one approach to
this or relative to the occupation of
the 41 units so that's and I don't have
any
um commercial information regarding the
delivery of the scheme that Churchill
are describing
um so you know at the moment what I've
got is a recommendation which is
open-ended in terms of program if you
wish to explain what you're doing what
I'm getting at is this we'll ensure that
and block any
each of the down the road can change
their mind on the Bellevue house site
so of the house only yes so this is this
is the conversion of Bellevue we have
not discussed as officers what the
timing is that they particularly have we
know that one of the uh a potential
developer of that says he's not going to
proceed with that it's a commercial
Market they may do it themselves I
believe earlier they were saying that
that they have done other other
conversions for themselves one option is
for committee to require that conversion
to have been commenced by a point in in
the development occupations based
sometimes time-based difficult where
you've got the market to consider and
that's why officers are recommending to
you that you leave that as a matter for
us to take away but it is the committee
to choose if they wish
can I ask for clarification through
YouTube and through the chief planning
officer perhaps of Our Guest
did I hear you uh correctly sir that
from an operational point of view you
must have lview converted before you
have residents in your blog yes I mean
we we sell our Apartments I mean
you know our residents average resident
purchasing a 78 years of age we can't
have them work on walking onto a
building site and the point of trying to
stress is that the construction cost
involved in building 41 Apartments is is
is huge and we cannot afford to have
Bellevue house sitting in the background
dragging it back
to you within the 106 would you accept
Bellevue must be converted prior to
occupation of your units in the I think
if it was related to occupation I think
to have something before that may be an
issue and but if it was related to
occupation and that's certainly
something that should be considered
acceptable
if I can pick up that conversation
chairman what without doing negotiation
on the floor of a planning committee
what was being proposed
um I believe was that the scheme would
be converted prior to occupancy you
described a problem with having
occupations take place with without
Bellevue being in position I mean from
our perspective and I I I I suspect it
might be something you might wish to
take away and come back to offices on
um as members debate carries on that
might be a way of doing this German so
that we have
uh some timetable that we can then
present to members about when this this
may happen and can be locked into the
section 106.
so if you're happy with that chairman
I'd suggest we uh we allow that to
you I'm happy speakers to consider it
and then give us some position on that
okay not to give officers a position on
that this afternoon well now you know
now yes
I
was I think that she planned off as a
sort of resolved my question to be fair
I mean the developer
very firmly stated that they would have
the Bellevue House Development finished
before
and the necessity and the constraints of
the site I would imagine deter you know
lead to that you can't have if you say a
building site on Bellevue house when
you've got a development that's already
occupied so I think the developer was
quite firm on that we just need to make
sure we've got it in writing so Jim may
I suggest when you've finished with the
public speakers and everything has been
explored there and we move along if I
have five minutes and I'm sure Mr Pierce
can ugly help Committee in my absence
I'll have a conversation with them and
then report back to you
Comfort break please yes yeah okay thank
you
thank
you
I was just going to say that could
presumably be part of the delegated
decision in the construction management
plan sure five minutes something along
those lines five minutes okay it might
be that Mr Isabel can have that chat
with the um applicants during our
comfortable
am I switched on oh that's better yeah
um I have just warned the chairman I'm
very sorry about the Practical
inconvenience I know this has been a
long day already and quite a few
um practical problems have delayed us I
I've just been given an eye and the
monitoring officer Emily you will have
just been given some information by a
member of the committee which means we
must give you legal advice in private
and find something out and resolve an
issue I hope it can be done quickly but
I'm afraid I must advise the committee
that for that to be done this is an
issue of probity and for that to be done
properly I need to advise you
to pass a resolution excluding the
present public briefly so we can deal
with received completely you can receive
legal advice in private
I'm very sorry ladies and gentlemen if
if the committee passed that resolution
but there's space outside I hope um my
office all of my officer colleagues are
not present public but you don't all
need to be here you might like to join
the public as well just leaving
um those around the table here
um that's my advice to make a proposal
I'll propose it we propose remember
exactly that councilor McGraw second is
it all in for anyone all in favor show
of hands please
thank you that's past right thank you
will
clear the floor
what time is it sorry what what date
performance
um the legal officer and the director
for governments have statements to me uh
yes indeed um are we we're back in
session we've readmitted the public
formally I think are we on live stream
everything is is as it should be
um chairman ladies and gentlemen thank
you for your cooperation I'm sorry we
had to ask you to do that
but yep thank you for your cooperation
I'm sorry we had to ask you to do that
um what I I can say is the monitoring
officer and I have made some inquiries
in private spoken to members we we have
ascertained that a document was
privately given to some members of the
committee
what I must say is all I'm going to say
is that that is on its face a breach of
the council's planning Charter a
significant irregularity I I don't want
I wouldn't like anyone to make any any
further assumptions beyond that it may
not necessarily have been any bad
intentions or anything worse than that
but I the monitoring officer and I've
discussed it we have tried to persuade
ourselves otherwise because we know
there's a lot of inconvenience involved
but our reluctant advice to members is
that this item should not be
um
finished voted upon this afternoon and
so that that is our advice that Mr
chairman to you and your your fellow
members the monetary officer might need
to add something possibly
if I may committee members um obviously
this is a irregular matter which will
need to be investigated I will be
contacting you to arrange for interviews
and statements to be taken just so that
we can be fully aware of the situation
that has occurred while that
investigation is undertaken members I
will remind you that the legal advice
given to you in the adjournment is
confidential and the details of this
issue are also confidential
so while the investigation is underway
please do not share the information of
the particulars of the matter outside of
the council thank you
okay so as this matter is being
investigated so this meeting's adjourned
I apologize to all the people who are
not going to get their planning
application heard this afternoon I'm so
sorry but we're in a legal dilemma and
that's that's the meeting is close I
think well chairman I think we if if I
may I think we ought I would advise that
you formally resolve to defer the
remaining business of the agenda to
another appropriate occasion
volunteer
I don't say Holton times it Busby
and show of hands please
thank you meetings closed
sorry
[Music]